ans
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
oui ma personne
alors mademoiselle vous avez enfin
obtenu zermatt
c'est la troisième fois je vous demande
ferme à wizz air mag en suisse
lagence belloir priorité police c'est
madame la préfète elle-même à l'appareil
c'est au lagarce elle a raccroché
mademoiselle mademoiselle s'il vous
plaît seal team elle ne décroche mais
plus les bâillons c'est plus simple
comme ça alors ariane connor rien mais
ça dit quoi
comme mon chéri je n'avais pas vu mais
qui a pourtant accordé une mélodie il
paraît qu'il était au golf et que je
pense en effet qu'il n'était pas encore
ça mais ça y est c'est signer les
nouveaux mais non il d'après fait plus
de police nous sommes liquider le
secrétaire du prince malo voyons une
école non plus ce que nous aimons
beaucoup nicolo est bien assuré que le
décret était sur le bureau du prince
mais qu'il ne l'avait pas encore signé
mais c'est une question de minutes et
nous devenons quoi je pense ce qu'on
nous le dira je m'étais moi ce que nous
devions la risée de la bracine son opus
viable le décret n'est pas encore signé
mais déjà il n'est même plus moyen
d'obtenir une communication téléphonique
je voulais des commandes et la villa
thermale pour cet été impossible les
standardistes ne décroche même plus aux
hommes de la police dans un pays c'est
le fondement de l'autorité la passe de
la discipline
la garantie de la morale est ce que je
voulais dire au prince la vie dont il
n'a pas vu j'avais pas compris c'était
pour tout de suite moi en général ce qui
n'est pas pour tout de suite c'est pour
jamais le ministre des finances a
décrété la procédure d'urgence galerie
mais pas naturellement pour l'arrivée la
balance des comptes est en déficit
constant à leur place
il a imaginé ce économie comment ce que
je crois c'est à dire que ce n'est pas
d'être une idée de paul rivet ah ouais
tu n'es 2 qui de sa femme c'est évident
mais ce n'est pas la police qui est visé
avec les hells c'est moi aussi
parfaitement gilberte rivet a toujours
été jaloux de moi elle était jalouse
tout quand nous étions en pension val
était jalouse de mon style andy sa
passion de mes toilettes puis plus tard
2005 dans les appartements qui donne sur
les jardins du palais les bâtiments du
ministère des finances ont douté elle
tristesse quand je dois dire que nous
n'avons plus rien à leur envier
nous aussi nous fournir via cette
affaire tout est à refaire et gibert
hypocrite avec ça je les rencontrais ans
nourrit guère chez le coiffeur
je suis arrivé à l'été sous le casque
m'a payé au titre et nature et griffé
non mais je récupère la tête j'avais la
tête c'est moi tu perds la tête quand je
suis la seule à voir clair que toi comme
un saut il a fallu qui favorise ses
proches avant moi je favorise le bon jeu
parfaitement toi quand tu rentrais le
soir du bureau et je te demandais alors
chéri quoi le nouveau team répondu et
comment rien pas de hold up que de
meurtre pas de vols nos séries non grâce
à ton mari
grâce à notre police si bien fait il ne
sait encore rien passé aujourd'hui
alors oui merci gorge tôt plus de ris de
veau
quoi le boucher qui nous gardaient un
ris de veau tous les matins il ya de
répondre à gorges pour qui la demande du
plus vieux rivaux plus de priorité
police plus de villes à zermatt hurgues
nous n'avons plus droit à rien à lire
les journaux tient rien pour ce matin en
allemagne attaque d'un fourgon postal 40
millions de deutsche mark enlevés par
des bandits masqués en angleterre
nouvelle victime du syndicat la moto en
france
on va alors là ça marche c'est fou trois
cambriolages de hold up
quatre prises d'otages en suisse en
suisse dans le canton de vaud
c'est pas grand enfin ces tout petits le
canton de vaud eh ben ils ont quand même
un crime passionnel
toute rencontre un crime passionnel chez
les suisses un agent de change fou de
jalousie vide son chargeur sur son amie
la femme d'à banquiers et voilà et chez
nous rien n'est à eux mêmes n'ayant
depuis cinq ans à néons dont je suis
fier c'est un conte parfaitement sont si
fiers que fut pierre d'avoir fait de mon
pays grâce à des méthodes un pays sans
violence vol sans escroquerie fin
crémeux cents sans prise d'otages et
demain sans point nice om et ol avait
tout prévu sauf ça sophie v a traîné sa
jalousie sauf le manque d'imagination de
nos ministres avoue que le raisonnement
est tout bête
il faut faire des économies mais rien de
plus simple pourquoi garder une peau
lisse puisqu'elle ne fait rien pour sa
paroisse aussi n'y voit sa balle
la dde tu étais sur deux branches je te
jure que ton père figurait pas revenir
sur le tapis le droit de revenir sur le
tapis mon père et comment le plus grand
préfet de police de notre histoire qui
bonnes âmes attention s'il ya un sujet
sur lequel je ne tolérerai pas qu'on ait
remis c'est pas par hasard
sur le liffe de message ni madame a sans
doute oublié l'individu qui attend dans
le petit salon c'est vrai rien type qui
va demander qui t'attend depuis 20
minutes
les 1res heures le rosier langues et
albert landais reviennent berguois
onésime s'en fiche au dossier entre
apple et rick notre service de
renseignement l'indiquent comme caissier
aux établissements belmont et sardines
salut albert l'aube et nous étions
pensionnaires ensemble au lycée
maintenant je me souviens là quand j'ai
succédé à son père il avait été le
premier à peu pressés de présenter ses
félicitations
je veux tu peux bien vouloir il a appris
ce qui t'arrive
il veut être le premier à te présenter
ses condoléances mon coup droit tenant
du titre ont très bien très bonne élève
toujours prix d'excellence très bonne
éducation pas d'humeur à tentant de
bêtifier sur tes souvenirs de dortoir tu
vas tu devras son acquittement mois
seul monsieur le préfet que ces
désespérés ces cui bono mi janvier
comme on veut tous
l'envié ça fait plaisir de te retrouver
je vais devoir que son excellence se
souvient encore de moi en disant je t'en
prie jugement la paix avec son
excellence au lycée en stuc loyer tu vas
me faire le plaisir de continuer à
baisser qu'au lycée en blouse grise
c'était facile l'antique ici
et si ce tournoi tutu j'ai essayé ça
c'est toi qu'est ce qui t'arrive
voilà mon vieux pardon je veux dire
voilà ce qui m'arrive c'est ta français
je me souviens toi tu es la seule fois
où j'ai eu la moyenne en composition de
mathématiques
c'est le jour où tu m'avais passé ton
brouillon et puis aussi au concours de
commissaire de police à mais là je t'ai
déjà fiancée avec la fille du préfet
mais rate le dollar est alors depuis
tout ce temps alors tu devenu quoi bein
je ne suis pas devenu non je suis resté
conserverait unix et les sardines arish
événements as tu le connais en pape
allemand tu parles je les rencontre est
très souvent bien la chasse aux oeufs le
prince soutient plusieurs fois oui je
sais que monsieur paiement est un
habitué du balandre à son ami personnel
de sa majesté alors tu m'as compris et
tiens je vais demander un service une
fois pellemans un service important
ah bah oui ac oui tant mieux alors comme
ça tu es directeur commercial chez
belmont directeur commercial non
racontable simple comptable
premier contact ne comment toi un élève
surdoué comptable chez belmont imagine
toi qu un jour comme ça pour remplacer
un cousin malade je suis entré chez
welmant comme caissier pendant les
vacances
en attendant en attendant quoi je ne
sais pas j'attends toujours
bah moi tu vois pendant tout ce temps
c'est merveilleux d'être ainsi redouté
honoré inspecté avoir une belle
situation infréquentable par ex qui peut
pas que tu fais pour l'avenir comptable
chez bell bombe
c'est plus sûr tu sais dans certaines
circonstances
cette certitude peut disparaître c'est
même la raison de ma visite je suis venu
te voir comme amis mais aussi comme
préfet de police a peint alors écoute de
toujours nous mais parce que ton avis je
le resterai toujours mais préfet de
police marc van gundy d'eyl c'est simple
et affreux j'ai volé cac volley oui oui
mon vieux j'ai volé mais tu as volé
qu'il faut les volets où tu as volé
volet non j'ai j'ai volé volée j'ai
commis un vol
un seul oui mon vieux un vol donc tu
t'es bien vol
je dis bien toi langil oui moi landi
toile en titre a commis un vol
oui moi l'envié j'ai commis un vol
mais c'est impossible si hélas oui mais
tu as volé quoi de l'argent acquis à
belmont patron mais voler avec
effraction ah non non non monsieur merci
non d'ailleurs
c'était bien inutile volet avec
effraction quand on a la clé du coffre
c'est une idée qui me serait pas venu du
bois non
non j'ai volé de la façon la plus
naturelle enfin pour un comptable vous
avez besoin d'une certaine somme
d'argent dont je ne possédais pas le
moindre sou alors je les représente et
je l'inventé à la caisse de la maison
sans rien dire à personne j'avais
l'intention de la remettre
trois jours plus tard demain le jour de
la paye
mais la chance était contre moi hier
l'expert comptable est arrivé
inopinément pour vérifier les livres
j'étais sorti pour une course je n'ai
rien pu faire c'est ainsi que je suis
devenu un voleur tout innocemment
après quinze ans d'une vie exemplaire
d'une carrière sans poche - inverse
landes il faut pas te mettre dans un
état pareil que tu veux tu manipuler des
sommes considérables que toucher un
salaire de misère alors pas forcément un
jour ça devait arriver
non on voit tu pour moi c'est pas toi le
coupable merci jules mais là tu réagis
plus un ami campus alors pas idée quand
on a un collaborateur de la qualité que
le laisser moisir dans un emploi si
médiocre annonce a franchement bellemon
n'a pas volé et violé combien cent mille
cent mille cent mille francs anciens
comment sont les français
me aba même il fallait crever que me
lefaure il m'a enfin la somme importe
peut faire c'est le geste qui compte
gelé comme moi que je sois je peux que
m'élever peut-être une suite tuera les
remettre dans la caisse et tu reviendras
fechter fait maintenant c'est trop tard
c'est trop tard les contres sont fermés
les les livres sont entre les mains de
l'expert le pot-aux-roses va être
découvert peut-être même l'éthique des
gens je suis un bon concours du
dramaturge le futur que tout peut encore
se rendre maîtres et bellemans je lui
rendrai ses mille francs je lui
demanderais d'arranger la faire sans
bruit et crois moi je suis sûr qu'il
acceptera
mais alors il faudrait
et tout de suite là oui c'est apparu que
l'on met tout de suite immédiatement bah
oui à la minute et sur qui n'a pas
oublié le service que tu lui a rendu on
voit bien sûr un peu lorsqu'il s'en
souvient pas je lui rappellerai comme
sur moi je dis donc toi maintenant
qu'est ce que tu vas faire
ben si ça conduit pas j'avais pu rester
si tu vois ce que si dehors je
rencontrais quelqu'un du bureau si je
tombais sur monsieur bellemans par
verica tout à fait raison bon bah écoute
tu resteras lille saint-etienne tu
déjeunes avec nous et si et si et si
c'est pas arranger ce soir tu couchera
dans la chambre d'amis je vais prévenir
madeleine
je lui ai souvent parlé de toi elle sera
ravie de te connaître hors jeu pour
installer monsieur dans le petit salon
servait lui l'apéritif dans les rues de
quoi fumer des journaux afin que
personne ne le dérange pas tout de suite
je ne sais pas quoi dire j'ai joué je me
sauve la vie world a cité a tout de
suite à l'eau à tout à l'eau ah oui
à zermatt laissaoui ne quittez pas
mademoiselle une seconde une pilule je
harel madeleine la matinée
alors mademoiselle face et moi d'urgence
lagence bellewaerde je vous prie belle
belloy be2 lots aux badauds vous n'êtes
pas dire - non mais qu'est ce que ça
signifie
je vous ai demandé herman ne manger que
lorsque vous l'aurez c'est insensé il va
se tuer des standardistes
tiens encore un résultat dette et
méthodes il est parti dans la bataille
et non non non il est dans le petit
salon je voulais te dire si ça te
dérange pas ton riz afin que ceux qui ne
voient pas devant la caisse qu'il ya les
bains il va probablement déjeuner avec
nous trois pour lancer des invitations à
l'improviste
tu choisis toujours battue c'est mon
joueur spécial taxe n'est pas
aujourd'hui que je vais commander de la
kiwi je voulais te dire aussi il va
probablement être obligé de quoi de
coucher ici abadie le tout de suite il
est venu passer ses vacances chez nous
non mais en vérité la de crozon et le
prix y est elle a flanqué à la porte je
me dis que celle qui m'a dit alors qu'il
est vain voilà ils l'ont dit deviens de
m'avouer quelque chose d'assez graveur
il a volé il y là bas il a volé il a
volé mais il a volé un homme dont il
faut les voiles et il a il a commis un
vol à voile oui un vol qui dit bien
valorisant je dis bien un voile taux
longs 10 wi lan qui a commis un vol à
folle selon la définition légale code
pénal livre là un article 61 c'est pas
possible tu dis ça pour me faire plaisir
non je te dis ça parce que vient de
l'avouer il a volé quoi de l'argent un
vol bien qu est ce que tu entends par un
vol bien un volume anormalement bas
maintenant heureusement non les screen
sa place quand cory disco très
importantes plusieurs millions 100 mille
francs
cent mille francs l'ancien une phrase
qu'on avait mis sa cavalière dont
madeleine ne le juge pas en vironnement
il est comptable cheminement il a eu un
besoin subi de sept soldats il à présent
qu est il quand elle armait temps il a
été surpris en somme rien de bien
terrible d'ailleurs c'est ce que je vais
expliquer de ce pape appelle mans me
lefranc quand on a sa fortune
c'est pas grand chose dit franck langue
à la porte et qu'on n'en parle plus mais
surtout qu'il ne porte pas plainte
ce pauvre landier et déjà cette nuit
comme ça il est inutile qui sont en plus
déshonoré si gilles est ce que tu n'es
pas devenu subitement fous fous pourquoi
comment pourquoi
voilà cinq ans que nous l'attendons ce
vol nous l'avons même tellement attendu
que nous allions disparaître avant qu'il
n'arrive la providence nous l'envoie
justement pour le couperet va tomber et
tu arrives à arranger l'affairé skah
monter le coupable notamment de l'onu le
volume et le voilà c'est tout ce que
c'est je n'écoute rien et tu n'iras pas
si j'irai l'enquêté ici par son joli là
et qu'ils me voulaient promis d'aller
chevènement je lui ai promis le formal
moi la confiance en moi et en tout temps
mort à la morale je sais que les voleurs
soient punis par des chercheurs
allemands d'être élu à la mairie aux
communes et je peux mettre dans un état
pareil le gouvernement a lui en en fou à
mettre en route ce train d'économies
budgétaires occupants qui sait bien qui
va pas le stopper pour un bol de mil
neuf cent mille francs c'est ce qu'il
t'a vous et il ne fera peut être pas
tout dit il a peut-être volé dix fois
cette somme sans fla attends attends
cent fois mille francs dimming savez 10
millions au lendemain que folle parce
que toi policier tu as confiance dans ce
que tu as dit un ami à un bowler sous
prétexte qu est un ami belmont aussi est
ton ami c'est le volet non madame la
préfète mais il ya là deux messieurs de
garde nationale qui vient de faire
l'inventaire du mobilier
déjà ils disent que si en prévision de
sa récupération
allez dis à ces messieurs que son
altesse n'a pas encore signé le décret
wallon et l'eau je leur ai dit madame et
disent que toute façon ce qui est fait
sa fin les vautours ils n'attendent même
pas pour le détrousser que le cadavre
soit mort bon je ne veux pas les voir
quand je peux je ne veux pas les voir ce
matin qu'il commence par l'office
je voulais parler comme c'est une jante
ici que je suis entré directement défaut
ça fait bien fait capitaine je préfère
vous devinerez jeunesse qui est allégé
belmont les amis n'a lui pas un vol
c'est ça mais qui vous l'a dit il à
villé oui c'est ça je devinais enfin
vous par exemple transmission de pensée
il était étonnant alors les premiers
comptages est en fuite a nommé lundi
albert hélas disparu hier soir à l'heure
qu'il est peut-être loin ce qui vous
fait croire sa capitaine on flaire de
falling été ne trompe jamais on a besoin
de secret faut que j'arrive avec les
jarrets bon si on n'avait pas vu ça fait
si longtemps que russel a heureusement
on ne trouve plus rien j'ai découvert
mécontents
lundi ils étaient venus se réfugier chez
moi donc plein de confiance peut être
obligé de l'arrêter foncière nous
n'avons pas le choix nous n'avons qu'un
voleur et c'est lui mais en tout cas je
n'aurais pas aisé non surtout pas si ça
ça relais qui doit l'arrêter rieur il
faut trouver un moyen de le faire sortir
maintenant mais moi qui l'avait invité à
de jeunes et vieux ça m'embête tellement
de recevoir oui tu t'en charge de la
charge facile pour une fois pour une
fois qu'on a besoin de toi environ à
lévis alors damas dès le premier mois ne
pas être trop désagréable mais lui je
sache alors je serai également gelé sa
fille survenue mc12 n y aurait-il eu
l'idée romantique
monsieur que dans le petit salon et la
salle à manger n'est pas finie rester
ici pour qu'elles matinée allô oui le
cabinet du prince
le secrétaire particulier mais bien sûr
passer le mois alors bonjour dicolo mon
arrivée à y bien partir pour le bureau
vous pensez avec tout ce travail ce
matin c'est belmont a téléphoné
directement au prince
oh mon dieu il presse a décidé que tant
que les voleurs ne serait pas arrêté il
ne signerait pas les décrets qu'il a sur
son bureau
c'est pas possible du collège je rêve
c'est trop bon j'ai bien compris
si on ne retrouve pas ce voleur nous
restons préfet dont je me pose ier le
sursis oui dans l'es8
grâce aux petits minables qui attend
dans le salon regardez qu'est ce qu'il
fait en ce moment
regardez vite ils regardent la pendule
vêtements aux c'est parfait vous le
faites entrer j'ai fini merci les colons
merci de nous avoir rappelé qu'elle a
mis presque bozec
je n'oublierai jamais au revoir bonjour
monsieur je suis madame la préfère les
hommages mon mari m'a mise au courant de
votre situation
malheureusement j'ai une assez mauvaise
nouvelle à vous annoncer
avant même que j'aie eu enfin parce que
le préfet parce que tu arrivé chez lui
belmont avait déjà porté plainte contre
vous que vos les malades je n'ai que ce
que je mérite c'est la loi je vais de ce
pas remettre on en sort entre les mains
de la police
vous voulez vous rend mes qualités mais
pourquoi mais parce que c'est naturel ne
pas inviter au monsieur dsk naturel pour
un voleur aux nombreux vous excusez pas
madame c'est le mot juste
sinon ça je serai à bercy je vous dise
que naturel pour un tous les gens que la
police recherche
voilà c'est ça c'est de s'enfuir de se
cacher non j'ai déjà causé assez
d'ennuis à mon ami monsieur le préfet
mais c'est son métier à jules ii vous
courir après il est payé pour saluer
tous ses subordonnés c'est pas une
raison parce que vous êtes son ami
d'enfance pour vouloir lui éviter ce
souci mais croyez moi monsieur vous lui
rendez un très mauvais service non mais
je n'ai pas le courage de fuir
je suis tellement sûr qu'il me rattrape
rend tout de suite alors là ne soyez pas
si pessimistes ils n'ont pas tellement
l'habitude et vous avez l'air tellement
plus intelligent qu'eux on on veut me
convaincrait pas alors je comprends très
bien que monsieur le préfet n'ait pas
voulu m'arrêter ici mais je vais aller
me rendre à lui dans son bureau où il
atterrit monsieur madame que voulez vous
que je fasse aboutir fuir fuir et vous
cacher je ne sais pas quand vous avez
volé comme quand vous avez pris ses
mille francs vous avez vous aviez bien
prévu un endroit où vous pourriez
disparaître si l'afer tournait mal ah
non non non pas du tout non
on n'a pas idée de voler avec tant de
légèreté il faut trouver un endroit où
personne née l'idée d'aller vous
chercher maintenant et le trouver
rapidement cet endroit parce que ça ça
devient urgent va chercher un peu
monsieur aidez moi je suis là bas mais
je cherche madame je cherche je me
débats mais l'amour si je n'ai pas
l'habitude de fuir en général je passe
inaperçu je vais look unique témoin ici
le ciment au sûrement ici ce ici ici
mais vous avez raison mais c'est une
merveilleuse idée mais bien sûr vous
allez vous cacher ce nom pas d'âge
non je disais ça impossible
réfléchissent et qu'ils gravagna vous
cherchez dans l'appartement dix préfets
one i am songe ici je suis un voleur
alors non je ne veux pas que par amitié
pour moi monsieur le préfet courant pas
irréaliste il sera ravi
j'adore depuis notre mariage il ne s'est
pas passé une semaine qu'est ce que ça
lui joue ce qu'il me parle de vous de
votre amitié d'enfance si touchants il
regrettait que je ne vous connaissent
pas et ben voilà qui est fait grâce
évidemment j'aurais préféré que ce soit
dans d'autres circonstances mais vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point je suis
heureuse de vous avoir rencontré et je
comprend l'engouement de jules ça vous
met très très sympathique et je ne
pourrais pas supporter l'idée de vous
savoir en prison
ça vous revient nicolau wade nous leur
avait donné un mois aux gens série
gauche
nous l'avons échappé mais hier c'est
tout ce que voulait faire ton ami
landier non aller à ton pire on
s'arrange pas possible un peu fou non
non non il faut qu'ils se sauvent un qui
trouve une cachette sur rajalu et
trouver la meilleure ou ça ici ici ici
ici à may hamm et oui mais
ici à mais c'est une idée géniale tout
simple mais il ne veut rien entendre
je vous dérange et ami de juillet nous
dérange jamais personne ne sait que tu
es label syco orge pour j'en fais mon
affaire
il met tout dévoué il était déjà
policier au service de mon père alors
allez accepte et à madeleine à une
cuisinière formidable elle réussit tout
sévère c'est au nom je vous assure c'est
impossible c'est l'heure du déjeuner
vous allez rester ici vous passerez
toute la journée avec nous et puis
demain tranquillement prendre une
décision définitive
alors puisque vous insistez tellement à
moi oui c'est drôle vous ne l'était pas
allez vous installer je voulais aller
bien mon dieu il ya deux pattes à illats
ébroïcien de ma part c'est dans la boue
allomo l' agence mondiale presse le
rédacteur en chef va passer de moi
j'attends bonjour comment allez vous si
si je suis au courant de la sphère
bellemans n'avoue pense événement est un
de nos amis quoi mille francs non enfin
mon cher ont plaisanté
enfin vous étiez au courant vous des
dispositions qui allait être prise au
sujet de la police
vous pensez bien qu'on ne les a pas
annulée pour un vol de 1000 francs au
nom là la vérité c'est que le trou
représente plusieurs millions c'est une
affaire qui s'annonce colossale une
escroquerie de classe internationale
howie attention je vous dis ça entre
nous pas question de le publier
oui oui oui bah rappelez moi si je suis
autorisé à vous dire quelque chose je
vous promets en amis je vous le dirai
au revoir à bientôt ça peut marcher
pourquoi pas et maintenant si dieu est
dieu et quelques autres je vais la faire
revivre mois la police de papa
[Applaudissements]
de suite 3 à acer monsieur landier si
vous aviez connu papa mais je sais que
je peux faire c'est un très grand chef
le plus grand de notre époque monsieur
passionné de son métier
si vous aviez vu ce qu'il en avait fait
la police avec quel talent il avait
organisé avec avec l amour
il ne vivait que pour elle nous avions
des inspecteurs les commissaires des
officiers et des sous-officiers et des
coupables des coupables
partout la maison était pleine ici
parfaitement
nous avons toujours eu des détenus comme
domestiques télé quand j'étais petit
c'est un escroc qui m'a appris à compter
et savez-vous qui m'a servi d'honneur un
satyre on qui était l'autre maître
l'hôtel pikpok avec une fiche de paie et
puis comme nous l'avons pas eu de
détenus nous avons dû nous rabattre sur
les policiers mais on dira ce qu'on
voudra pour tenir une maison savons pas
des voleurs
encore un peu de brillance je vous
remercie de jeu j'ai pas peur
si vous mangez les émotions ça creuse et
pilar brio aux assauts répétés coller
avec brio
voilà papa une vague de criminalité est
magnifique
gilles l'éventreur ce n'était pas pas
tout mignon le proxénète des baronnes
c'était pas le faux monnayeurs torrent
qui imprimait ses billets sur les prés
semaine que l'imprimerie nationale 7 et
papa et j'en oublie avec monseigneur
puis lui il faut achever pilleur de
troncs admirable figures du crime
c'était papa s'était pas fait attention
quand je ne souhaitais pas pas je veux
dire c'était du temps où papa effet près
fait bien si j'ai bien compris
papa disait toujours ce sont les grands
policiers qui font les grands bonheurs
laisse pas qu'elle est bonne cette
brioche monsieur le pâtissier l'a fait
spécialement pour nous mais c'est moi
qui lui ai donné la recette est sympa
qui avait fait construire notre prison
modèle 180 cellules ultramoderne vue
panoramique à conditionner musique douce
on lui avait reproché de voir grand à
l'époque mais voyez-vous il était comme
ça papa l'arrêt mais je me perçois vous
n'avez pas encore goûté la confiture
d'orange amère
vous devez refuser je ne nommerai pas on
a fait spécialement pour nos amis et
pour nous ça goûter tout de suite tout
de suite c'est une fois là vous me
donnez franchement votre avis alors
j'attends
alors c'est la fameuse dream orange au
mercy ça qu'on fait plaisir qu'est ce
design et pippa peau et des yeux
et puis papa est mort et
j'ai eu la tri sa place et très vite
tout ça a péréclité un jour nous n'avons
plus de délinquants fait plus de détenus
alors évidemment la prison modèle est
devenu inutile savez-vous ce qu'on a osé
en faire des hlm mais vous le saviez
mais j'y habite
est ce que ce n'est pas une honte je
confortable je ne le fais pas dire
monsieur l'orgue et vue panoramique à
condition d pour des hlm
vous avez il les aime mais ces
prisonniers pas parce que vous les
bulles a toujours eu de son métier
une vue trop trop simpliste mais pas
pour lui pour lui il ya d'un côté les
honnêtes gens qu'on laisse en liberté et
de l'autre les malhonnêtes l'on mette en
prison
et puis c'est tout alors que ce n'est
pas ça dans mon produit tomorrow c'est
une vision manichéenne des choses il ya
tout un monde entre les deux le milieu
les gens qui constitue pour la police le
fonds de clientèle ce sont eux qui lui
fourniront toujours la grande affaire
mais à condition qu'on joue avec eux
qu'on les laisse aller et venir et se
pardonner
on dit toujours un repris de justice et
bien pour qu'il soit repris il faut bien
qu'on le laissait s'échapper
voyez comme tout ça et levant c'est
encore un peu de thé chaud on veut être
comme moi vous aimez le tennis pas
encore quelque chose qui nous lie il en
a eu des gros rouleurs pas parler il
avait des crises et de volume ce sont à
la fois ses mémoires et son testament
spirituel
dans le premier il raconte en détail
tous les grands vols tous les crimes
spectaculaires comme lio pole de sa
carrière le second ce plutôt sont les
tics de la police il faut absolument
vous lisiez vous allez être emballé bon
oui non le futur je pense que ça vous
plaira beau j'en suis sûr la ja c'est
pas du tout pour le grand public mais
pour jules quel guide
s'il avait voulu enfin s'il n'avait pas
été le médiocre qu'il est non madame ça
je progresse mais on a le droit de
gagner
jules est votre ami mais il faut dire
les choses comme elles sont placées à la
tête de notre police jules s'est révélé
d'une incapacité absolue et prétentieux
avec sarah palin toi justement ah ben
dis donc toi ça a l'air d'aller 1
j'en ai honte à moi c'est de l'art
fidèles tout va bien la robe de chambre
tu trouves voici mais beaucoup mieux
qu'à toi d'ailleurs je viens lui donner
ah bon alors maintenant pas de gars s'il
te plaît ce n'est plus tard hot de
chambre c'est la sienne
je n'allais pas moi un jeu d'aidé
s'approchant climent la porte un peu
plus des shows et bonne idée quand je
conserver notre invité à donner du sucre
goûter singer tient à jeudi près
d'étaples
alors je bosse tout va bien tout va bien
monsieur le préfet bord mais j'ai appris
des choses
ah oui quelque chose c'est vous pouvez
parler de voir notre invité dans un pot
nous n'avons aucun secret pour lui
vous savez que j'ai mon indicateur
personnel auprès du capitaine par la
tient à oui oui sa femme de ménage
d'après ses enseignements le ministère
des finances avait proposé à barlatier
si prince avait signé des train de
devenir directeur de l'organisme et qui
date heure et par l'ati elle est
acceptée oui mais on le traitera était
le prince n'a pas signé sané pensons
plus n'y pensons plus n'y pensons mais
j'y pense
gore je peux vous êtes sûr que par la
tienne a pas un indicateur personnel
autres et moi si bien su kwajalein que
madame la préfète se rassure c'est moi
quelle hypocrisie sa part attiré alors
il s'était bien gardé de nous parler de
ça et heureusement que tout est arrangé
enfin pour l'instant
pour l'instant et et pour quelques temps
j'espère vous n'imaginez pas à quel
point nous sommes heureux de vous avoir
et c'est sincère tu sais bien hier soir
quand nous avons été seul homme abdel ne
tarissait pas d'éloges sur toi embauche
rue eu beau mais qu'ils le sachent et
intérêts ben tu sais pas ce que de tous
les copains que je voulais présenter un
hacker le seul avec qui ça ça a collé
tout de suite va être en retard
le bureau oui d'accord alors ne pas
occuper pas bien du lien et surtout ne
le laissent pas seul un tu sais la
solitude c'est pas bon quand on est
seule excuse je n'ai jamais eu de la
délicatesse quel sens très
approximativement il a été si bon voila
mais vous aussi vous avez terminé
oui madame là vous avez votre journal
vous les voulez cigarettes non je ne
suis même pas le matin parce que ça me
fait tout seul
merci beaucoup oh ça c'est un patineur
famille si canal qu'est ce qui se
profile à sion mais regardez là en
première page
or on a le grand cambrioleur de la baume
au coeur de plusieurs millions ont
disparu pour ça y est on est un sens
avec ma photo notre photo alors là je
comprends que vous soyez furieux cette
photo ne vous avantagent pas du tout à
ça c'est pas la photo cc plusieurs
millions j'aimerais me prend et on
m'accuse d'avoir escroqué plusieurs
millions à 171,1 millions elle a
découvert là j'espère exemple d'une
centaine de militants mais on pense que
le cambrioleur qui était considéré comme
un professionnel d'une classe
exceptionnelle professionnels hommage je
m'en serais bien passé et madame aaa a
commis ses hôtes a réussi à camoufler
ses autres détournements à knauf et 7
scandale jeunes est d'abord mis 9 jeux
ne s'est pas passé comme ça je vais
écrire à ce journal moi j'avais envoyé
un démenti cinglant si vous faites ça on
va vous retrouvez votre trace tout de
suite je ne peux pas laisser passer ça
sans réagir
non mais c'est insulter les personnes
suivant le cimentier a changé un million
c'est du moins ce que vous a déclaré le
préfet paul ii soit proposée c'est pas
possible ça je ne peux pas y croire il
n'a pas pu faire les armes et bien sûr
tout non il n'a pas pu faire ça avec
vous connaissez les journalistes vous
pensez bien capable c'est un corps sans
le moindre fait divers et cinq cents
donnés à coeur joie
non madame sur plusieurs millions
plusieurs millions ont aplani vous savez
plusieurs ça commence à 2 alors
c'est ce qui me reste à vous inquiéter
parce que le temps de m'habiller le
court au bureau du nom ça vous ne fait
pas ça non vous dirai pas chez jules
pour moi il me semblait que ma vie
recommencé hier quand vous êtes entré
dans cette maison ne me dites pas que
cet espoir et des gens fuient je suis
voyez-vous n'a pas seulement gâché sa
vie professionnelle il a gâché aussi sa
vie sentimentale est la mienne en même
temps en fait je ne suis jamais aussi
seul que quand je suis avec lui
et depuis hier depuis que vous êtes
entré dans cette maison il me semble que
tout est changé par votre présence si
vous avez comme j'étais heureuse de vous
entendre parler hier soir j'étais
d'accord sur tout ce que vous disiez
n'est ce pas je vis avec un compte
eh ben c'est fatigant à la fin la vienne
non non non je procède non le désert
médical je ne vous permets plus rappelé
madame je vous demande de m'appeler
madeleine
comme je vous appellerai albert
mais là je suis très touchée je ne sais
que dire donc on vous remercie
je ne peux pas laisser croire que j'ai
volé des millions bref vous en seriez
parfaitement capable vous ne pensez pas
ça si je le pense et je vous en prie ne
ne prenez pas mal je pense que vous
faites partie des grands il y avait
grand préfet quel grand policier il ya
des grands comptes à mais il ya de
grands escrocs
je ne sais pas si je dois me sentir
flatté quand je pense l injustice du
sort à votre égard vous le brillant
sujet aux et julie et julia accumulant
toutes les chances
il a surtout eu la chance de vous
épousez de mire autant c'est vrai ça
s'est lassé c'est vrai mais c'est gentil
de le dire
ça me touche beaucoup à la pompe à
mahdia madeleine marquette lez lille
madame madame non par madame adler
je vous trouve tellement tellement
tellement quoi d'habitation attention à
ce que vous allez dire je sais j'ai
l'air comme ça de commandes et de
décider de trancher ce n'est qu'une
apparence vous savez une une défense
voilà je suis très romanesque au fond
oui très très faible très même très
fragile je ne sais pas c'était pas très
bien de votre part de profiter ainsi de
la situation vous êtes vous êtes
pardonner c'était de ma faute aussi
je ne vais pas dû vous montrer à quel
point vous m sympathique et quand je dis
ce sympathique s'est faite moi c'est
raymond albers et où vous me trouvez un
peu trop franche je le lis dans vos yeux
c'est oui c'est un de mes problèmes
voyez vous je n'arrive jamais à masquer
mes sentiments mais je voulais dire je
suis une faible alors cette fois plus
dramatiquement à quoi pensez-vous des
boîtes où je pense à cette histoire de
millions franchement dans la l'instant
c'est charmant ça c'est agréable non
mais l'oeuvre d'al amil français d'ici
peu d'argent que je pouvais garder le
sentiment d'être resté honnête surtout
avec l'habitude je pouvais obtenir un
non-lieu
tandis que des millions non c'est çà
cette eau de malhonnêteté vous en prie
de vous mettez pas à parler comme je
sais j'ai donné l'émoi madame amon
adapter votre honnêteté votre l'été vous
servez à quoi va connecter à rien trop
table je suis belmont confiné dans un
placard son zahera ligue et les chiffres
sans autre perspective que la myopie
précoce la retraite misérable
permettez-moi de 1000 francs par mois
pour calculer les centaines de millions
que votre patron vous appelez ça un
médecin m'a donné cette meilleure que
l'était quand vous mettez retombé en or
albert albert rassurez-moi ténois je ne
suis pas tromper à ce point sur vous qu
on cravache et belmont mais quel intérêt
du 20 %
quoi oui madame du 20 % à peu près c'est
le taux moyen que me rapporter les
sommes que je prenais dans les coffres
de monsieur pellemans pour mes
opérations personnelles que vous avez à
son personnel
hier ce n'était pas votre premier vol si
hier oui autrefois auparavant c'étaient
des emprunts des emprunts oui vous
remettiez l'argent dans la caisse a pour
sa part fait toujours scrupuleusement ça
c'est long c'est le rêve de tous les
comptables gagner de l'argent malhonnête
sans cesser de rester honnête seulement
en général ce sont des médiocres alors
ce rêve ou bien on ne le réalise pas le
rater ce pont en or tandis que moi je
l'avais réalisé vous mais bravo
messieurs
et c'était quoi ces opérations par
exemple c'était très variés des prêts à
très court terme des coûts de bourse des
tiercés puis lui plus ou moins truquées
mais alors soyons francs maintenant en
quinze ans que ça a dû vous rapporter
des millions oui peut-être seulement je
ne les ai pas volées sont des millions
qui n'ont pas coûté un centime à
monsieur belmont je comprends maintenant
pourquoi vous êtes resté si longtemps
chez lui
robin c'était pour moi la place idéale
bah voyons melman avait en moi la plus
entière confiance et je peux le dire
sans me vanter elle était bien placée
ouvrir à tous ces cahiers était
parfaitement tenu ces additions
impeccable ses bordereaux insoupçonnable
ça me regrettera sûrement ah oui alors
pensé que pour 1000 france
ces grottes alberge vous a connu tout de
suite nous rappeler les meilleurs
clients de papa où il faut absolument
vous disiez celi
ils sont décrits pour vous les ouvrez
n'importe qu'elle parle ça vous accroche
tout de suite aux néo hasard tu avais le
cambriolage de la banque nationale viser
un malade de la vente nationale 27
juillet 1922 à apporter 3 millions de
francs or à son auteur rester impuni on
ne l'a jamais retrouvée jamais l'homme
l'homme qui avait agi seul avait préparé
son affaire avec un souci du détail et
minutieux un enfant de 10 ans aurait pu
exécuter
c'est passionnant c'était sûr que ça
vous intéresserait cambriolé des notes
mais quelle joie d'avoir trouvé enfin
lecteurs digne de pap a cité sa main
quand je suis heureux
jules décidément il n'a pas encore assez
de travail ni repos bien mérité
merveilleuse journée joué plein de plus
ce matin là c'est une merveilleuse pluie
rafraîchissante bienfaisante
voila voila je dois donner des ordres à
la cuisine je voulais ces viseurs vieira
à tout à l'heure c'est l'heure
tu entends elle chante en ce terrible
qu'est ce qui est terrible eh ben mon
vieux j'ai pas osé le dire devant tel
mais ça va de nouveau très mal
vous avez entre les mains traces non
dieu merci mais les experts comptables
ont établi que je suis belle non tu lui
n'avait vraiment pris comme ils le font
à même la vérité a éclaté
ah oui mais ça n'arrange rien ben quoi
mais parce que le ministre des finances
a aussitôt contre-attaqué disant qu'il
était absurde de maintenir toute la
police une activité pour un vol aussi
ridicule
le décret est revenu sur le bureau du
prince et si le signe c'est la
catastrophe quand madeleine va savoir sa
terrible surtout pour vous pour toi
aussi ne nous serions expulsés de cet
appartement ne pourrions plus le garder
et une échapperait pas à pas relative
s'il n'y avait plus de police
je ne risquerai pas mais ne croit pas
aux fins le composent ce j'aurai cet
organisme liquidateur que par la pied
justement pour diriger et un organisme
aux liquidateurs comme ça tout les idées
et les patins ce liquide toi même alors
tu m'as compris et elle ça se bouscule
pas ça se pressent pas le hara-kiri est
un sport pour lequel on se bouscule pas
ce mot climat est alors barlatier me
garder en prison
ben tu penses bien qui va pas te laisser
en liberté pour que tu viennes l'enquète
mais risque de me garder combien de
temps enfin ça c'est fois tenir avec toi
jusqu'à sa retraite est tout jeune
or ils sont foutus là tout le temps
c'est terrible ça mais ben oui c'était
un as tu vois tu vas lire ça allait trop
bien lire hier j'étais heureux je
t'avais retrouver madeleine t'avais
adopté halte mbuku tu sais a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
elle a l'air un peu comme ça l'avait
dans le fond c'est une sentimentale et
quand elle à quelqu'un la bonne frau
tout lui est permis mais alors tu crois
qu on doyen fais ce qu'on fasse faudra
un miracle
est ce que tu entends dans un miracle je
sais pas vous hein pour crime un énorme
scandale en détournement d'avion je sais
pas pourquoi alors un vol mais alors un
vrai seulement rien de tout ça ne peut
arriver mais pourquoi pas ben parce que
mes méthodes policières ont rendu tous
ces dérives mathématiquement tout est
possible je suis victime de mon génie et
toi aussi tu vois bien mais je vois bien
je vois même très bien
bon ben moi comme changer un peu les
idées je m'en vais faire un peu de
lecture dans la chambre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça s'est passé entre 1h et 2h du matin à
la banque nationale la banque nationale
et du fait qu'ils ont remporté 20
millions un million devant pas du tout
d'après les premières constatations
le cambriolage a été un modèle du genre
le meilleur demi n'a rien vu rien
entendu
voilà cambriolés cette nuit le grand
coffre de la banque nationale 20
millions disparus le tandem nous avait
porté bonheur c'est formidable
nous n'avons aucun indice aucune piste
de travail de m un cambriolage ne
rajeunit de oui mais bien sûr monsieur
ne quittez pas voulez vous la tribu de
rédacteur en chef
parce que moi alors le poste est
l'appareil
bonjour c'est le niveau de quoi vous
faites une édition spéciale jusqu'à 38
spécial
une édition spéciale de bézieux écoutez
chers amis je donne une conférence de
presse à 16 heures au ministère de
l'information vous aimez pas non non non
rien pour l'instant en commun à rien
mais alors rien du tout au revoir c'est
la ville avoir aucune édition spéciale
ça ne leur était pas arrivé depuis
l'armistice à mes enfants c'est la
gloire quoi si je dois faire amende
honorable qui portait sur toi des
jugements sévères
les regrets les honneurs mais jamais on
t'a pas ne te quitter un jour d'accord
bricolage de 20 min en voiture et ça
c'est un coup de chance
je ne prends pas au bout de chance elle
a raison pourquoi être aussi bonne c'est
déjà que fier de toi comme de papin à
l'eau qui annonce tout de même dit que
je l'avais une conférence
il n'a qu'à venir enfin s'il veut bercy
qui s'était tu sais que ça qui nous fout
car elle fout car elle du grand écran
le spécialiste de l'éditorial indignés
pour
pour y réclamer notre tête et voulait
savoir ce qu'ils valent pas le plus haut
pour lui ça conclut lot celui là et
savez-vous ce que m'a dit le prince
avait déjà filtré ces pauvres il m'a
fait appeler aussitôt qu'elle était
encore en vie ce matin son altesse
n'était pas un goal nord s'est déjà vu
le prince pour un coffre fort perçu mort
albert ne vous ne vous rendez pas compte
mais dans des pays comme la suisse ou
nôtre mais le coffre-fort et la richesse
nationale
on ne verse pas au le profane la
suppression de la police à la
suppression de police il n'est même plus
question d'amener la main des trades à
l'audience a été d'une gentillesse il me
dit mon chien préfet je devine les
difficultés de votre taf
surtout que vous n'êtes pas habitué oui
c'est ça si vous avez besoin de quoi que
ce soit n'hésitez pas à me le demande
mais personnellement c'est accorder
d'abord rayonnages ma mission c'est une
forme de table julien babin combien
j'étais content pour eux à l'aise
imaginez-vous j'ai appris la nouvelle
j'ai mon confrère pour caserne de police
du vieux quartier
si madame avait lui cette explosion du
joueur surtout que déjà le bruit courait
qu'on allait être augmentée augmenté
d'un monsieur le préfet quand des gens
étaient payés si longtemps n'a rien à
faire on peut pas leur donner du travail
sans les augmenter
il a raison gilles après tout il faudra
vous avez raison dans le rôle dans les
favelas ce que je fais
allô oui c'est almere bonjour monsieur
la télévision le journal télévisé bardot
si nous sommes au courant de la sphère
de la banque nationale monsieur nous ne
parlons que de ça oui au war reportage
en couleurs c'est très délicat ce que
vous me demandez là je dois en parler
longuement avec monsieur le préfet ne
quittait pas le magazine féminin elle a
décidé qu'aujourd'hui c'était moi la
femme du jour où ils voient le film est
en place à risque élevé monsieur la fin
d'un fonctionnaire doit savoir s'effacer
une violette pour que vous êtes trop
gentil monsieur gros gagnant puisque
vous insistez tellement et bien si oui
là comment tout de suite le journal de
midi aujourd'hui mais monsieur je ne
fais jamais prête noms anglais au
laissez moi un peu de temps vous êtes
perry vous les braqueurs sont des gens
roulent c'est non je préparais moi ma
trousse à maquillage ma grande capeline
mon sac en papier mais quand ils veulent
me filmer en couleur dans les jardins du
palais mettez tous à leur maxi famiz
marron oui peut-être heroes nous en
studio après pour les gros plans mais
j'avoue quand je promets sa fille
je salue et la télévision les journaux
tout le monde commence à parler de nous
ça y est nous sommes redevenus un grand
pays et ce n'est pas tout ce n'est pas
tout encore albert son affaire et
arrangé nom déjà
mais comment tout à l'heure au milieu de
la foule mon général qui j'aperçois dans
les couloirs bellemans lui-même avant
lui alors là j'ai pas perdu de terrain
je le fais entrer dans mon bureau je lui
explique qu'un ex qui venait de nous
arriver nous n'avions pas de temps à
perdre à rechercher mille francs je lui
demande de retirer la plainte comme un
service personnel j'insiste je lui
rappelle
c'est un souvenir n'a rien à nous
refuser mais bref pour finir et
l'acceptant il est formidable
alors tu restes encore ici quelques
jours ce prochaine tu rentre
tranquillement chez toi et tout ça est
arrangé tout ça est oublié
pardon il ya une ses articles dans les
journaux les accusations infâme
oui c'est vrai il faut que balmont lui
fasse des excuses pour écouter mais
enfin il faut comme un bateau pour
demander un bon alors je te promets que
les journaux rattrapant sa un lino cent
des gens n'auraient à la légère c'est
vrai voilà ils sont maintenant albert
quel effet ça te fait c'est drôle je
n'arrive pas y croire
je parie bien retrouver la petite valise
de madame chercher là d'enjeu pour
chercher la recette malherbe inquiète
pas j'ai tout mis dans le sac et que
c'est bon
à tout à l'heure si cela ne marche pas
faire à temps
a bien dit il ya des années que je
n'avais pas vu aussi heureux et ça ne
fait que commencer à mon vieux puisque
jeté là il faut que tu me donne un coup
de main
on nous y mettons tous les deux avec ton
intelligence et mon mon expérience nous
allons faire un coup d'éclat on va te
coffret sept cambriolages avant qu'il
est eu le temps de faire pour oui mon de
l'arrestation foudroyante
c'est ma méthode ah oui mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya ça plaît pas ben franchement
non et pourquoi sa part parce que s'il
arrête tout de suite ce voleur avant
qu'il eu le temps de faire ouf comme tu
dis demain tu vas encore te retrouver
son travail comme hier battu c'est où ça
va et vous menez ah oui évidemment
évidemment à ça c'est le grand danger de
l'arrestation foudroyante
oui oui mais quand même ce ne l'arrêtons
comme ça en 24 heures les populations
vont nous admirent et ça va nous valoir
un tel prestige qu'on n'osera plus
ramassa si vous le coffret trop vite ce
cambrioleur les populations pendant ce
monde-là faire et d'être simple à
vaincre sans péril on triomphe sans
gloire
oui oui oui oui oui alors toi toi tu
ferais traîner oui un peu beaucoup
alors qu'on soit radin trop on va dire
que nous sommes les incapables
on dira au contraire vous avez bien du
mérite de ne pas vous décourager dans
une entreprise aussi difficile d'un
point de vue les miens point de vue de
thé [ __ ] c'est aussi celui de ton beau
père quoi pendant ces quelques jours
j'ai potassé série nom en entier ça fait
jamais que deux mille pages et alors il
dit quoi le popperle attend règles
fondamentales d'une police bien menée il
ne faut jamais arrêter un voleur toro
vite tombe premier page 12 ab j'avais
pas lu jusque là il ne faut jamais
arrêter un voleur trop vite et oui ben
belle formule mais ça veut dire quoi
tango pl explique le rôle de la police
est de maintenir l'ordre public
vrai le maintien de l'ordre public exige
une police prestigieuse vrai ou faux
vrai une bonne liste prestigieuse que si
elle arrête des voleurs prestigieux
continue je te suis c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ne faut jamais bail en juin
il ne faut jamais à arrêter un voleur
trop vite
18 sur 20 mai mais évidemment évidemment
évidemment et moi qu'il avait toujours
pris pour un imbécile le bon papa qui
vole un oeuf vole un boeuf à temps pour
l'arrêter qui les volait un boeuf c'est
sa règle arrêter le voleur dans un boeuf
c'est évidemment plus prestigieux
d'ailleurs et autres pendant tout le
temps que la police secours après le
voleur la presse le public rend suivre
des efforts s'intéresser à ces
opérations espérait renoncer espérer de
nouveau chaque fois que le voleur a
échappé à un piège
il provoque l'admiration du peuple les
femmes en devient amoureuse
les hommes jaloux et c'est ainsi que se
prépare la rénommée glorieuse du
policier qui après les avoir laissé
échapper 99 fois ces voleurs les arrête
la centième ce sont les grands policiers
qui font les grands voleurs et vice
versa mais finalement évidemment avec
l'arrestation foudroyante ça non plus
c'est pas possible de faire a dit ce
sont les grands policiers qui font
l'écran voilà même quand même un petit
détail qui m'inquiète
à la fin tout de même ce voleur gelard
est pourquoi comment pourquoi parce que
c'est mon métier
pas du tout comment pas du tout pas du
tout ton métis de courir après les
voleurs
rien ne t'oblige à ne pas rater on n'a
jamais évoqué un policier parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas à arrêter un voleur
vous aimez mais si on n'arrête pas on va
se [ __ ] de nous n'est pas du tout
jules sont bas les victoires qui font
les héros ce sont les batailles j'ai pu
quitter et si le voleur
finalement on ne l'arrêté pas plusieurs
réfléchis plus je pense que ce serait le
mieux
je vais essayer tu vas réussi sur tous
ses tubes être conscient moins oral b r
je sais que tu es toujours aussi les pas
tort quand je pensais le monde
tu sais ce que tu vas faire tu va
démissionner de chez belmont et je
t'embauche à mon cabinet ni aucun
diplôme attaché le cabinet est le seul
poste dans le monde d'aujourd'hui où on
ne demande aucun diplôme et ce sera bien
fait sur cette phase de paiement fait
d'accord n'ont pas refusé
tu gagneras quatre fois plus du tube
elmo et plus des avantages en tous cas
moi je considère que tu acceptes et en
attendant nous allons mettre tes
principes pas serein de ton beau père
oui oui oui au principe en application l
ennui est l'ennui c'est que mes hommes
n'ont jamais appris à courir derrière un
voleur sans l'arrêter ça évidemment
c'est toute une éducation à refaire
après pâques 1 en do you qui se laisse
aller à son naturel et qui me le camaq
ce voleur sens mais la catastrophe
battu sur ce point je reste optimiste
mon flair au tu parle déjà comme un
policier être l'effet de l'atmosphère
ambiante
mon frère me dis que ce voleur a
retrouvé une excellente quel bruit en
ville
pour ne pas retourner les techniciens
qui s'y connaissent m'ont dit que
j'avais la photogénie d'alice sapritch
cima + cycle de dix habitations abîmées
toutes ces dames d'abord j'ai eu une
alerte apparaît comme attendu on va tous
qui sait quand albert il faut que sony
ne s'en soient proclamés par la presse
comme un fête nationale qu'il devenait
trop aussi comme ça on l'invitera avec
je t'ai déjà dit que j'en faisais mon
affaire d'autant plus que tu ne sais pas
tout il ya du nouveau directeur des
bâtiments officiels qui veut vous parler
personnellement il raciste
qu'est ce que je fais c'est aussi le
directeur du mobilier national women now
jules il vient de faire ses excuses
j'espère que tu vas lui dire ce que tu
penses de louis de ses procédés les
esprits brantômois qui bavent tampa on
est aussi téléphone pour dire que
monsieur gbagbo avait retiré sa plainte
c'était une erreur mais il a envoyé un
communiqué où je vois ça n'a pas traîné
je suis bien content pour monsieur landi
du j'ai toujours eu confiance
mon amour grâce ma vie et du mois c'est
que c'était ça nous voulons parler si je
suis si un patient bien jules veut que
je travaille avec lui dans son bureau
dans son cabinet c'est bien une idée de
caucus avait gardé que jamais la coke et
c'est merveilleux ne me quitteront plus
embrasse moi je reviens voyons toi tu
m'aimes plus haut mais si je t'ai non là
c'est quoi cet abécédaire moi je ne sais
pas j'ai pas l'habitude qu'est ce que tu
veut insinuer que je les vois d'habitude
à le faire attention à ce que tu dis
mais je t'en supplie what you no more to
great suffi au petit regret ouargla et
pourquoi ça ne s'est pas poursuivie pour
des raisons d'amitié et de loyauté et de
fidélité vous avez dit bizarre les
hommes
bien sûr il est certain que je trompe
jules sous son toit on ses portes à fond
tu peux pas sortis aux attentions gorgeu
j'ai retrouvé ma dont la petite valise
de madame mais savez-vous à l'état et
non sur la plus haute et agir de la
penderie avec pour aller la chercher la
meilleure de toute façon il n'aurait pas
pu il a donné à madame la serrure est
détraqué elle sauve tout cela alors il
faut la porter à réparer tout ça pour ça
la vie des jeux retrouve palette mais
pourquoi la vue des alévis aimerait
maintenant elle pèse pas comme une
balise blanca eeckhout et je leur
nouvelle vie c'est pas la peine qu'on
voit pas comme ça je vais là je vais
l'ouvrir mois ci enfin sur ridicule je
dois avoir un doute que cette clé
quelques pas quand je pose dans le temps
ma chambre
vous verrez dans le premier tiroir de la
commode vous trouvez une petit bois qui
doit être super coach adjoint mais je
trouverais et merci beaucoup m
nouvelle a dans les cabinets avec gilles
on regarde regarde ce que j'avais fait
pour que disent pas tous les jours avec
les yeux avec moi tu vas la pause et
cette famille inquiète
délicatement puisqu'il vient avec cette
valise donc voilà il faut que gta vous
quelque chose
hier soir je suis sortie qui est sorti
mais tu fond oui non mais je suis allé
chez moi pour récupérer des documents
des souvenirs de famille que je ne
voulais pas laisser traîner dans
l'appartement oui j'ai emprunté cette
valise en d'annoncer une imprudence fois
ne raconte pas ça julie ne te
pardonnerai pas aux halles rien dans
cette valise mes souvenirs de toute ta
vie
les souvenirs de famille physique c'est
très émouvant que j'aie mer dans des
décors vous savez pas ce qu'ils me
voulaient le directeur des bâtiments
officiels à me demander si ça ne me
dérangeait pas qu'on refasse mon bureau
ça faisait cinq ans albert cinq ans que
je n'ai réclamer ces travaux et d'un
seul coup il me remet tout à neuf les
lambris les oiseaux mais il est où le
rideau les moquettes
il doit m'envoyer les échantillons il
parle même de me mettre de la moquette
pourpre et or et la moquette
c'est ce qui m'a dit vous préparant ces
merveilleuses albert mais parce que
c'est la moquette réservé au ministre
les hauts fonctionnaires n'ont droit
qu'à la grille souris et les services on
pointe de vaches et tous
ça nous le devons à sa valeur mais c'est
le père noël est en berne à leur boulot
tu dors mal et moi pas du tout mais
cette valise à la buvette et ça s'est
passé votre petite valise
oui c'est marc sénant tiffany zamora tu
ne reconnais pas la serrure est détraqué
je dois la porter à des paris merci
merci merci à mathieu carlat qui
l'attend il à double piston là la
réaction
mais qu'est ce qu'ils demandaient qu'est
ce qu'il me veut encore nous arriver
c'est tant pis t'as pas la bonne on
connaît pas arrêté sur sa personne il
est capable d'enlever les sites à faire
foi alors là c'est la résidence et de
l'imprudence faut aller dans votre chien
coûte il croire monsieur rioux sera pas
dans le bus que c'est à cause par la
télé je sens que ça va être terrible je
suis sorti très bien bas le mieux qu est
ce que tu veux le mieux est de se jeter
à l'eau mais on achète toi d'en rire
alors on attend le reste va venir
l'emporter
tu me diras si je m'en suis bien sorti
je suis là ils ont ajouté que je reste
avec mon mari nous affolons pas il ne
faut jamais arrêter le voleur trop vite
il ne faut jamais arrêter un voleur trop
vite beau quand je pouvais tomber le
capitaine bernard seux le préfet et les
cui cui
puis mon père dont il souhaite parfait
mais je voudrais prendre la clé de la
valise son côté grands chevaux ou plus
chez nous la paix avec cet hommage à
l'affairé n'est pas pressé alors asseyez
vous prenez le quoi écrire et vous
noterez mes décisions qui disiez vous
parle à pied mais qui est cuit mais
notre homme se préfère le cambrioleur de
la banque nationale puis imaginez vous
arrêtiez je vous arrête moi monsieur
préfet mais je suis innocent
[Rires]
non non non je veux dire je veux dire ne
vous emballez pas on est beaucoup
ce prêt fait que nous avons une autre
une empreinte fruits de ce préfet une
empreinte de doigt parfaitement visible
relevés sur le coffre même est faux
c'est naturellement fausse pourquoi
fosse pour vous inspire à neyron
barlatier
c'est enfantin pas possible impossible
n'est pas policier
elle formule monsieur le préfet merci
gorge pau par mathieu vous plaît nous
nous envolons bon elle revoyons baladi
possédons méthodiquement vous avez
interrogé le veilleur de nuit tout de
suite vous pensez les bords et al
il ne savait rien c'est sûr c'est un
prince oui oui il vaut mieux un témoin
qui ne sait rien qu'un témoin qui
donnent de faux renseignements vous
allez reprendre son interrogatoire faut
être vraiment sûr qu'il ne sait rien il
est marié
oui vous interroger sa femme il a des
enfants noël vient avec sa belle-mère
vous interrogerez la belle mère et le
beau-père en bd muet
il est muet sont élevés oui il est muet
où il fait l'alluré où il ferait le muet
depuis 76 ans alors là ce qu'il est mais
oui bon ben ça fait rien vous
interrogerez des voisins je crois que je
vous assure c'est une fausse piste
et alors mais une fausse piste je
préfére il faut la suivre mais ne nous
mènera à rien une piste mène toujours
quelque part
le sort est qu'à constater qu'elle ne
mène à rien par là qui est encore une
fois vous vous précipitez mauvaise à
savoura de mauvais tours souvent dans l'
enquête policière qui croient avancé
trois vite recul rebelles formule
monsieur le préfet c'est qu'ils essaient
de moi bharati vous allez me suivre
cette fausse piste jusqu'au bout c'est
bien noté qu'au japon et bien noté
monsieur je préfère ça sur c'est sûr
c'est en grèce que nous tous partir vous
autres tu ou là où vous êtes têtu que
vous êtes têtu et ben alors allons-y
partons sur cette empreinte forte en
panne
mais ce pas la mienne me convient
évidemment évidemment et vous allez
trouver au fichier central l'empreinte
qu'il fallait même les l'instant aucune
ne corresponde à vos comms ombre vous
oui si aucune empreinte me correspond je
dis bravo parce qu'aussitôt n'est ce pas
cette empreinte devient très
intéressante à utiliser un cambrioleur
mais dont les empreintes ne sont pas au
fichier central
un bon n'ai aucune raison d'en laisser
des fausses donc elle est vraie
vous voyez sans me précipiter moi
j'avance
alors voyons comment utiliser cet
emprunt il faudrait pour comparer ont
des enfants de tous les citoyennes la
principauté outils dieuze agonie décor
je peux je peux fait vous vous rendez
compte du travail le travail ne nous
fait pas peur mais pendant ce temps là
monsieur préfet le voleur continue court
toujours
justement il s'essouffle pas et s'ils
continuent pendant il continue il
s'essouffle
c'est quoi mais s'il continue qui
continue si on commence siro comment
c'était là que je l'attends ce temps que
je l'attends mais comment qui vole un
oeuf volera un tough attendait pour
l'arrêter qu'ils aient volé un bug qui
veulent un peu mais maintenant vous
savez ça fait qu'ils votent donc
détaillé lapin qui vole le neuf un petit
test
voilà un peuple attendait pour l'arrêter
qu'ils évoluent en baisse car il est
tout de même plus facile d'arrêter le
voleur banques parce que le voleur
bundle mais monsieur prévost millions ça
fait déjà un gros oeuf
oui évidemment
évidemment oui mais enfin quand même
réfléchissez s'il laisse encore une
entente et que cette tempête ce soit la
même que celle que nous avons vous vous
rendez compte de notre avantage
ah non lui la trouver tout de suite en
jeu de la pole mais nous aurons enfin
des empreintes qui corresponde autre
chose
l'archiviste assure qu'en vol identique
avait déjà été commis avec le voleur
était pesante n'a jamais su il ya
longtemps 50 ans cinquante ans vous vous
rendez compte cinquante ans c'était nous
les appels trois heures que nous sommes
nous sommes pas en retard vers le rhône
à des détails sur ce vol il faudra
entreprendre un improbable de recherche
nous avons des tonnes d'archivés et pas
très en ordre ça risque de demander six
mois six mois six mois vous savez ce
qu'il vous reste à faire
fall dit m et tout de suite le corps
chevaux accompagné capitale mais logent
à sarakhs et je vous assure
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons perdu assez de
temps dans la lutte que nous avons
entrepris contre le crime
toutes les minutes comptent au revoir
mon capitaine a beau se réformer auger
l'impression d'avoir été assez bien ce
qu'il était difficile tu sais
l'animal tapage qui la midouze affirmant
dans sa poche ah je croit en effet
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons fait un grand
pas en arrière si papa table et il a dit
être heureux
bon j'avoue que j'aurais jamais cru que
ce fut si facile d'appliquer ces
méthodes ne serait pas facile du tout si
c'est toi qui as du talent et qu'est ce
que c'est que ce sont des souvenirs de
famille c'est de l'argent c'est l'argent
des billets tout navire bleu le cachet
de la bande banque nationale banque
nationale donc nationale 10 ce sont les
millions de la banque nationale
le cambrioleur de la banque nationale
c'est albert r non je vous écris moi
c'est en fait ce n'est pas dans un état
pareil qui ne seraient pas partis s'en
servent
et puis et puis quoi tout ce qu'il a
fait c'est pour nous jeunes ont remercié
pour nous sauver
ça c'est un ami mais chéri le mignon ne
portent pas rester là comment dans
l'appartement du préfet de police n'a
aucun style est plus en sécurité que
dans leur corps à la banque de détail
dans leur coffre à la banque
tu vois ce qui leur est arrivé
qu'allons nous faire c'est lui
nous savons que c'est lui écoute moi
bien mais lui ne sait pas que nous le
savons donc nous avons bahar sur les
vrais allons nous pouvons faire comme si
de rien était exactement prochain de
mieux ça nous faisons comme si nous ne
savons rien il faut qu'ils ne se doute
de rien et on tourne en matinée le monde
de mes collants
comment at il pu réussir cette couleur
avec un bébé doc hsbc table ça prouve
surtout que ce n'était pas difficile
je ne suis pas du tout au long du jeu le
revoilà écoute je le revois le premier
jour pour bouleverser pour un voile 2010
et aujourd'hui à les obtenir nous placer
mallet qu'il a évolué avec une rapidité
par la porte soit en chef de l'état
favorable de ça ne peut s'apercevoir de
regarder encore plus folle et non voila
voila on peut les actes eux mans comme
avant n'est pas le bagne à des farc a
volé quelque part non mon genou droit
avec l arrivée de s'ouvrir tout à
l'heure devant barlatier au 7e rang avec
à ses trousses
mais qu'est ce que je suis
c'est par là titres émis dans cet
éboulis
au fait tu terrible ça a été ça a été
affreux ça a été
par la biais a relevé une empreinte
figurez vous non non sur le cross rohm
and haas alors notre embryonnaires
génial comme une fortune sal et
barlatier a sauté dessus
mais il fallait voir comment gilles la
concret d'écouté derrière la porte
il a été il a été sans relief il a été
nul
si con après sentiment en ce sens que le
cambrioleur va remettre ce à quoi je te
dis que je le connais ton à deuxième
cambriolage nomades
tous n'y pense pas mais j'aime ce que tu
as fait au contraire mais enfin quand à
son premier coup les princes ce soir on
leur fait au bureau les peintures les
lambris les moquer pourpre et or on nous
a mis partout mais à son deuxième coup
zune on nous rendrait peut-être les
brigades d'élite qu'est rayonner dans
tout le pays et pouvait foncer à présent
à l'heure sur les malfaiteurs
hélas il n'y en avait pas mais ils ont
rêvé a réussi à les faire supprimer
l'année dernière c'est papa qui les
avait écrit il était moins la marraine
quand on les a supprimées albert c'est
comme si on m'avait arraché des enfances
or cela n'a été malade assume qui doit
nous venger de toutes ces humiliations
on nous a fait subir
on n'a pas demandé ton avis pour les
supprime un lot tu doit imposer leur
renaissance
et puis il faut que ce soit un premier
pas vers un avenir brillant sublime
tu dois être de grands chefs d'îlot
grande police qui doit déplacer papa tu
me cherches tu crois vraiment que je
peux atteindre ce sommet je n'en ai
jamais douté mais pour ça il faut battre
le fer pendant qu'il est chaud profiter
de la vitesse acquise
l'opinion publique est ébranlée il faut
la faire chavirer gravats jonchent les
raisons
c'est ça j'ai toujours raison mais pour
ça il faudrait que ce cambrioleur
naufrage
deuxième coup
deuxième coup ah oui mais oui mais oui
il faudrait que ce cambrioleur nous
fasse je deviens devient le coup il ne
pas le faire immédiatement
pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passait mais
vous n'avez pas les vacances
non moi moi l'avocat pas les rend tout
ça non je dirais même plus vous avez
l'air contre moi ton cou non mais c'est
de faire quelque chose contre 10 le du
le franchement pas du tout ce mois quand
je me voir d'exciter comme ça moi j'ai
peur que vous voyez ici mais je suis
parti à ce génie impossible la façon
dont il a travaillé prouve qu'il est
extraordinairement doué part il a tout
de même laissé notre eau ne petit
emprunt jeu de rien du tout à part
visible et encore n'est même pas sûr
qu'elle soit de lui un homme qui réussit
à bord de cette envergure nom n'est
évidemment pas à son premier coup et un
homme qui n'en est pas à son premier
coup nuit tombée non plus
et puis son succès devrait l'encourager
tout le même enfin quoi un million
justement 20 millions ça lui donne le
temps de souffler avant qu'ils aient
débarrasser ses 20 millions c'est pas
forcément un voleur économe
moi j'aimerais bien brillant généreux
comprend des bijoux de cadeaux une
maîtresse qu'il adore pas par exemple
alors
et croyez moi hein
il n'a pas intérêt à nous décevoir ou
non ce sont les grands policiers qui
font les grands voleurs
encore faut-il que les voleurs y mettent
du leur balise est toujours avec un
voleur qui n'a pas l'avenir il est
inutile de clairoix sont on le coffre et
puis alors là ce sera vite fait avec
notre empreinte co2 et qu'elle n'était
pas évident que depuis une en panne
super une empreinte pour le musée de la
police pas garantir qu'il le fera je ne
peux pas non plus garanti qu'il ne fera
pas mal mais à oui mais alors il faut
qu'il le fasse vite très vite
cooking est plus raisonnable ça veut
dire quoi vite dans quels délais en bas
je fais pas moi je vais le coquin je
joue qu'un flou c'est trop s'est pas
assez au contraire non mais trois mois
et notamment au moins un mois mais pas
plus moi c'est très juste un mois nous
ne montrons pas au-dessus d'amour
signifiant mois il n'a pas commencé mais
je le livre pour l'été vous de même que
le cambrioleur repère sa banque
enfin alors écoute je ne devrais pas ton
problème nous en avons partout mais bon
tu n'as vraiment l'embarras du soir
alors là bld il groupe ld sial comptoir
européen le louvre le comptoir
commercial
surtout que l'on sait aussi y avait des
facile oui lesquelles de comptoir
ben oui le comptoir commercial par
exemple tout est tellement vieux le dans
des labos l'accord entre augmente
le comptoir commercial 1 avenue wilson
en plein centre on peut toucher le
centre de la ville passer une heure du
matin y'a plein chante et danse au
premier tour ne pas paraître compte
accrue brio lâche qui a été fait à
l'époque au comptoir commercial il ya
encore les plats de salé oui mais louis
ya tous les plans de tous les jeunes
j'attendais d'elle
alors voyons comptoir commercial
évidemment alors voyons et bois au bois
au couple franchement ça ne me paraît
pas sorcier tout de même d'entrer là
dedans un bon alors voyons comment
attirer l'attention de notre homme sur
la possibilité d'un coup au comptoir
commercial
il ya un moyen oui pendant quelques
temps les patrouilles de nuit pour
éviter tout le quartier de l'avenue
wilson très bonne et et madeleine fois
encore qu'il arrive au coffre ah oui aux
ébats les lacs à passer par là par
derrière la parlent enfin il faut
connaître ce coin rue g task rôle du
square je crois que la nuit n'est pas
gardé bah oui faudrait que tu en sois
sûr bon ça peut s'arranger la city les
appareils de sécurité les signaux
d'alarmé sonnerie ah oui ah oui les
sonneries s'en va écouter tout ça
fonctionne avec les cités y'a qu'à
couper le courant
si pendant quelques temps sous un
prétexte quelconque une pale de secteurs
pouvaient se produire à heure fixe
ça pourrait tout de même donné des idées
à notre homme mon attention une fan de
secteur à heure fixe
tu crois que ce serait possible mais je
l'aurais c'est du monde tels que réponse
[Applaudissements]
avec tout ça d'ici un mois et des mois
j'ai confiance et puis alors moi moi je
le répète je le répète si d'ici un mois
il n'a pas recommencer je le livre à
part la team bondi
toute réflexion faite je crois qu'ils
recommencent à baisser mais merci de cet
optimisme
c'est vrai je voulais dire autre chose
jules ta proposition d'entrer dans son
cabinet ma décision est prise je les
accepte
art
[Applaudissements]
au revoir monsieur min pour voir ses
amis
merci d'être venus à bientôt j'ai
maintenant je vais prendre congé mais
vous avez le temps comme andorre ce qui
se fait à cette acception a vraiment été
une réussite
ce triomphe vous voulez dire atrion tout
simplement en effet madame vous avez vu
toutes les listes étaient là sont
achetés son père sans avoir échappé à
l'ambassadeur lorientais le ministre des
affaires étrangères cinq académiciens 3
attaché culturel ministre des finances
avec sa femme gilberte rive est malade
de jalousie et à et voilà les rondes à
notre soirée s'est terminée le prince
vous implanter un total de sept minutes
croyez que ça n'a échappé à personne
ces dames vous regardez toutes avec les
yeux mon fait en effet un grand honneur
que son altesse m'accorder là j'en ai
été aussi surpris que la tête mais son
adresse a voulu à la fois honoré la
monnaie qui ne sont qu'une erreur
tragique a failli mettre en porte de la
société et surtout surtout vous
féliciter pour votre magnifique réussite
auprès de mon mari
au fait où est il j'ai eu et à les
accompagner le prince jusqu'au palais
mais on dirait qu'ils s'attardent si on
buvait un dernier verre en attendant
donc c'est leur vie des gangs japon
tandis mois encore il voudrait que soit
pas un qui aurait déjà fait à la boulie
fi de nos invités belges avaient prévu
j'en ai mis de côté 1 quant à tous gorge
pour selon l'onu
tenez je suis sûr continent le plus fait
ils auront recueilli quelques
informations intéressantes on fait
d'extraordinaire commandant jamais de
rythme et ses camarades du poids du
policier c'est passionnant de réceptions
mondaines tous ces gens qui parlent qui
parle sans qu'il soit nécessaire de les
interroger bien millions 57
bravo c'est une bouteille que des
invités avait fauché au buffet il avait
caché dans le grand bassin chinois pour
l'emporter chez eux
les avants excellente initiative vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
merci messieurs je crois à notre
renouveau
je bois à la police passe hier et à ses
chefs
je vois la gestation de notre ennemi
numéro un du temps ramadan mais j'ai
pilleurs de banque qui courent toujours
mais qu'est ce qui vous prend en
marratier c'est que madame avec le coût
de la banque de crédit la semaine
dernière nous en sommes à 252 millions
disparus 252 millions mais vous n'y
pensez pas mais je vous assure
d'ailleurs c'est tout ça le 13 mars
bombe personnel revenus familiaux vous
n'allez pas le regretter c'est le foot
qui nous a sauvés in extremis mais 28
mars comptoir commercial 27 millions 27
millions commandant à qui nous devons la
reconstitution des brigades dissous
souvenez vous à fait exacts mais 18
avril société deskom 24 millions à la
suite de quoi le gouvernement a doublé
nos crédits ce qui nous a permis de
payer enfin les heures supplémentaires à
vos idéaux et de mettre en chantier les
casernes nouvelle ne fait qu aux
championnats européens pointent fillion
lendemain vous accorder de brigades de
avec leur équipement contenant 22 mai
l'union panthères 31 millions oui
j'appelle mes 26 18 juin crédit au père
28 4 juillet groupe est de 6 à 24 mois
sans quoi nous n'aurions jamais obtenu
l'escadron de six voitures radar type
chicago 75 que nous venons d'inaugurer
avec les trotteurs de la banque de
crédit ça fait bien 252 millions enfin
vous oublier l'extraordinaire publicité
que tout ça a valu à la principauté
les envoyés spéciaux du monde entier
corps d'origine aux hôtels et tous les
touristes que nous ont amené leurs
reportages
l'arsène lupin des temps modernes le
superchampion du cambriolage
vous oubliez vos une nouvelle décoration
comme andorre et vous oubliez enfin
l'élection de mon mari à l'académie
honneur qui rejaillit sur toute la
police vous oubliez votre quatrième
galons mon commandant oui il faut dire
que pourra obtenir tout ça monsieur
l'envié nous a beaucoup aidés
j'ai fait de mon mieux abbas après celle
ci en triomphant en effet on avait tout
de même 250 du million d'entrées en bloc
comme ça tu as ça fait beaucoup mais
c'est parce que nous avons trop de bons
voilà tout c'est trop tentant
enfin le commandant nous avons tout de
même arrêté quelques suspects 40
monsieur touché dans son vous avez de
certains sont absolument vous ne voulez
pas dire que leur innocence a été
établie officiellement donc bien sûr
sinon les auraient relâché mais
maintenant on peut parler conservons
prison indéfiniment on va vous n'avez
qu'à arrêter d'autres suspects relâcher
un peu cela fait leur ferme
une bonne âme le vent d'espoir comme
attendu nous remplissent arrestation du
pire le bar du coin
sachant que lors de sa réception
l'académie monsieur le préfet puisse
commencer son discours par ces mots
messieurs ça y est nous y tenons quels
débuts et pourquoi monsieur le préfet
arrivant à l'institut à cheval un an
derrière lui son voleur chargé de
chaînes comme vercingétorix au triangle
de césar c'est stupide voyons donc ce
sont les beaux jours de l'arrestation
foudroyante nous d'aller radio chantage
et d'extorsion et c'est fait vous savez
quand on voit dans n'oubliez pas que les
discours de monsieur le préfet c'est mon
job assez parlé polixe vous êtes tous et
même les hommes en dehors des métiers il
n'y a pas de conversation possible je
crois que je vais me retirer
nous avons ainsi menu de berck du
parlement de majoration corps au bureau
pour voir si tout est bien nombre à non
vous avez minutes commandant aurait
foncé par l'acier je suis épuisé ouais
c'est mon abri mais qu'est ce qu'elle me
veut encore à cette heure-ci laquelle
enquiquineuse alors darly
oublié quel méchant au centre
aujourd'hui oui c'était très réussi
merci sur la tête je me le disait encore
tout alors je suis désolé de t'avoir si
peu parlé dans toute cette cohue
cet aperçu plusieurs fois au buffet elle
n'a pas démarré
il est près de moi via ses mais
certainement elle veut vous parlez moi
oui bon je vous demande préfet encore
une conquête à votre actif je suppose à
auch encore merci chère madame mais
vraiment je ne méritait pas cet honneur
si je suis libre et digne et demain si
on en parle
le jour je voudrais je la connais that
accaparé c'est une ak bars auteur maudit
attendu mais c'est moi qui suis très
honoré maire est le ministre hamad
il devra patiner g7 allumeuse je ne peux
pas refuser les voyons c'est battant les
amateurs de messieurs c'est tout moi je
n'ai pas vu son manège pendant toute la
réception elle n'a pas cessé de te faire
du charme
la vie vous réserve de ces revanche
imaginez vous que je sors de chez le
pense une séance assez pénible je passe
à mon bureau pour prendre les dernières
éditions je jette un coup d'oeil sur le
grand écho j'ouvre la photo de nos
voitures et jolie écoute bien notre
pauliste princière est aujourd'hui une
des plus puissantes et des plus modernes
d'europe
et savez vous qui a écrit sa fougue à
rennes vous garer mais on s'aime
augareils le terrible fougue à rennes
lille et sarah dans le journal de
l'opposition avec les photographies de
nos voitures blindées valoriser la les
deux premières lignes
c'est en gros caractères notre police
princière est aujourd'hui l'une des plus
puissantes et des plus modernes d'europe
ça c'est une victoire d'andy lui manque
plus maintenant que d'être la plus
efficace
quoi depuis deux mois ne se passe pas de
semaine sans qu'une banque sont
dévalisés il prend ainsi le ministre des
finances dont lésiné sur les crédits il
serait temps que la police arrête tu as
enfin le coupable c'est ce qu'on aime je
n'avais pas lu jusque là les mecs mais
tu ne lis jamais jusque là mais c'est un
grave en rayon n'exagérons rien du sage
en rien celui dit le comte et qu est le
plus gros tirage du pays et est fou car
elle est le maître à penser de
l'opposition le prince mais très
attention à tous ces articles en août
avant de donner à cette perfidie la
réponse qu'elle mériterait quand je vois
qu'une l'arrestation du pire demande
qu'est-ce qu'il a une idée fixe
écoutez par latif alors oui qui le
prince quel prince comme n'importe quel
point je
bien sûr il est là ne quittez pas c'est
le prof
il a lu l'article depuis la trêve mes
respects si oui j'ai lu je viens de lire
c'est un scandale vous ne trouvez pas
ah oui oui de mots bien un fossé
dangereux sinon je vais convoquer une
conférence immédiatement comme suivies
d'effet suivi avance bien si une
arrestation lui aussi qu'est-ce qu'ils
encaissent coeur pourra tout subitement
ce qu'il veut sont coupables arrêtés
pour demain matin que ça donne sur le
permettez je vais prendre congé je vais
retourner plus je vais me plaît pas trop
où je vais faire pogner le meublé et
elle étudie les dossiers avec un peu de
chance mais c'est sa part la team et
surtout ne faites rien elles sont me
tenir au courant un pas d'arrestation
inconsidérés entendu vous a pas fait
pour ce soir monsieur non non
tu as peur je me méfierais de par la
taille et son quatrième gagnon lui a
monté à la tête
bonjour au nom au nom au non surtout pas
j'ai trop besoin de tout le shérif uspo
mouche et albert vous avez devant vous
un homme bien embêté vraiment vraiment
vrai donc cet article tombe on ne peut
plus mal mon cher albert tu le sais j'ai
en toi la conscience la plus totale mais
il sans vouloir te fâcher je vais te
demander de me jurez que sur ce que je
vais te dire tu garderas le secret le
plus jacques sauf qu'il est vrai sur le
mois je te jure je sais que je peux
quand ils sont maintenant s'il est
maintenant écoutez bien tout à l'heure
au moment de quitter le prince devant
l'escalier du palais il m'a demandé de
monter avec lui dans son bureau
là il a fermé toutes les portes regardez
derrière toutes les tentures pour voir
si personne n'y était caché puis s'est
approché de moi me regarder bien en face
et au moment où je m'y attendais le
moins il m'a posé cette question
mystérieuse
que savez vous du complot que savez vous
du complot que savez-vous de complot
c'est la question la plus affreuse comme
préfet de police puissent s'entendre
posés par son souverain que savez vous
du complot si le préfet répond quel
complot le prince pense aussitôt ça y
est je ne suis pas l'étendue je paye
très cher une police
et c'est moi qui doit lui apprendre
qu'il ya un complot ou alors le prince
se dit et c'est bien pire
mon préféré jouer les imbéciles c'est
qu'en réalité il est lui aussi du
complot alors qu'at-il fait eh ben mon
tour je suis allé vérifier si personne
ne l'écouté aux portes pour me donner le
temps de trouver une réponse
puis j'ai regardé longuement à droite et
à gauche et je le dis son altesse peut
dormir sur ses deux oreilles
nous avons là dessus
quoi je pensais avoir trouvé la réponse
parfaite
pas du tout c'est donc ma dit le prince
que le complot existe réellement
j'étais cerner j'ai répondu oui ce
complot donc je ne savais rien et qui
n'existe pas j'en suis sûr je venais de
le créer de lui donner une existence
mais pourquoi maintenant bien alors le
point nommé n'avoir pas parlé plus tôt
non j'ai gdra douillet j'ai dit que je
n'avais pas voulu inquiéter aller légère
pour une affaire que nous suivions de
cyprès qu'elle n'avait aucune chance
devant un bref je m'en suis assez mal
tiré
mes explications donc à müller
d'apporter au prince tous les
apaisements nécessaire et par là dessus
voilà qui nous font que sur l'homme si
plus de cet article de fougue à rennes
la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase
mais qui tombe qui donc calé a pu aller
raconter au prince cette histoire
funambule est que de complot comment me
le prince de la bâtie c'est moi non si
quoi pas moi vous me cambou est ici tout
à l'heure au début de la réception mais
qu'est ce qui vous a pris mais tu fais
du fou mais les aveux du fou fou
dangereux shifu voilier fois je vais
vous expliquer mais tu nous d'abord qui
ont fait partie de ce complot et qui
sont des conspirateurs et son puissant
bien organisés ils ont des trucs au
hasard j'avais peur cgt compris
mais je vous rassure tout de suite ce
complot n'existe pas
y a pas plus de complot que de beurre en
broche qu'est ce que tu sens que notre
photo de wever répète qu'il n'y a pas de
complot mais celui dont vous avez parlé
au prince mais c'est un faux complots
qui n'existe pas et n'a jamais existé
entièrement imaginée par mois que par
conséquent il n'aura aucune peine à matt
est l'idée lui tout à l'heure des villas
ception et sous la toise sébum que tu a
éprouvé le besoin d'en parler on passe
immédiatement et sans délai paraît
j'avais le prince a sous la main ce qui
n'est pas si fréquent j'en ai profité
donc ça qu'il avait l'air si intéressé
ben on se faisait l'intérêt semble vous
auriez pu au moins prévenir su je
n'aurais pas demander mieux mais dans
tout ça il aurait dû nous parler avant
dix ans que l'idée nous on n'est pas
venu si j'en avais parlé team aurait
sûrement interdit de mettre mes projets
avec ce ne fut pas du tout certain bon
an mal an il a bien fait de ne pas t'en
pas on autorise le mot en toi tu là pouf
pouf à défaut d'être aussi
mais comment cette idée folle a que les
plus chers mais dans ton cerveau
imagine toi que j'ai découvert au fond
du grenier
le manuscrit d'un troisième livre du
préfet poulaga inachevé nationaux qu'il
avait intitulé police et politique c'est
la cédraie cette idée le troisième
niveau de papa et manuscrits que je n'ai
jamais cessé mais alors moi je vous le
dis je vous le dis franchement mais je
commence à en avoir
mais alors mais jusque-là du préfet pour
la gare s'il jette à terre et que toi
aussi j'en ai assez je t'aimais pas de
ton virus de la police de désespérer que
me taper notre préfecture pour un
laboratoire
sais tu commentes après nos officiers le
technocrate et ils disent que nous
sommes des cobayes des cobayes qui en
ont bien profité fort finir tu viens
nous inoculer le complot les policiers
chaigneau à table complot comme les
enfants intelligents la méningite en toi
quand jules tu as tort sauveur du régime
tu seras célèbre devant l'histoire
urbaine histoire je m'entends pas
d'eux-mêmes juteux
dans l'histoire de la principauté ton
portrait dans les manuels des collégiens
pour que les concombres ajoute les
moustaches à lanton violet que l'on
remercie à non vraiment je me demande
pourquoi il a fait ça je vais te dire
pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce que piller
des banques moi je commençais à en avoir
assez
c'est tout
qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que tu dis
le pilleur de banque c'est toi tu as une
fois lyon le super cool cambrioleurs le
raccordement des montants lire le
bonheur du siècle c'est toi puisque je
te le dis c'est le bouquet d'alors c'est
le bouquet tout s'écroule autour d'un
mois et pour finir pour achever le
tableau j'apprends que notre super
cambrioleurs génial c'est l'homme à qui
j'ai ouvert ma maison j'ai garantit
l'intégrité que je m'engage au sondage
ils arrêtent des imprécations savez très
bien à vous à vos hôtes de ces bois par
un succès c'est que tu le savais mais
comme le savent et il est bon oui je le
savais nous ne sommes pas comme on l'a
tous eu que nous le savions pas parce
que je vous ai surpris là en train de
ramasser les billets la valise un pub à
nîmes alors
qu'est ce que tu veux chacun de tes
cambriolages nous valait désavantage
seulement moi à chaque cambriolage
je tremblais chaque fois davantage à
l'idée d'une imprudence d'une maladresse
d'une coïncidence qui ferait tout
découvrir
et puis je commençais à me lier les
manigances de barlatier alors voilà j'ai
mis cette idée un complot qui n'existent
pas que par conséquent tu n'aura aucune
peine à arrêter tu deviens le sauveur du
régime
bref un avis d'une police définitivement
sauvé tu ne risque plus rien ni moi non
plus il a dû signer je le pense aussi
parfois aux saveurs un sauveur le
l'hystérie collective c'est pas le
moment un jeu me dire quand on a quand
on a mis de côté 250 millions
bon on n'a plus envie mais alors là plus
du tout envie de se faire arrêter par
dont vous ne voulez pas insinuer cher
albert que tu vas garder cette fortune
si michelin signe rien du tout je vous
le dis nettement clairement formellement
j'ai l'intention de garder pour moi
c'est millions tout petit peu zone cela
loin du monde sur cru que vous réalisiez
ces cambriolages pour aider notre police
a retrouvé son autorité et son prestige
sa puissance mais je n'ai jamais imaginé
que vous garderiez l'argent alors pensé
que j'en ai à faire quoi de ces millions
mais madeleine cela dit les rentrer et
la rendre comment quant à qui et qui va
les rendre vous dois moi en disant quoi
on les a retrouvés
quand comment où alors
je sais pas moi mais je pensais que tu
avais faut noter sur la question ton
plan génial comme d'habitude si
compliqué de les rendre ces millions
c'est si simple de les garder même si
vous voulez garder alors vous êtes un
voleur et nous sommes très complices
pageau tafurs communes crac du gamin
gratitude
alors non mais julia complètement perdu
la tête tu m'a caché chez toi d'accord
mais cette à manger bigrement marange et
la ridicule affaire belmont tu m'as
appris à son cabinet mais je t'ai
renvoyer l'ascenseur non enfin souviens
toi de l'état dans lequel tu étais quand
j'ai frappé chez toi et regarde toi
aujourd'hui puissent ensemble et on
aurait sans douté parce que tout ça bien
sûr on peut le doigt la faiblesse de et
les plans diaboliques que j'ai dû faire
à chacun de tes coups pour diriger
terreur de renforcer dans les banques où
tu n'allais pas
des démonstrations ou disons qu'elle est
qu'il fallait arrangé pour qu elles
s'échouent c'est toi qui les conserver
et les conférences contre les
déchaînements de barratier c'est quoi
qui les tenait là si c'était douter de
quelque chose barlatier
et le portrait robot du cambrioleur
chauffe par n'y avait qu'une moustache
rousse c'est pas toi qui l'a fait le
cinéma est une idée à moi et le fameux
décret du 23 mai tel décret fin de
l'année obligeant chaque banque pour des
raisons de sécurité a changé chaque
semaine le numéro secret de ses coffres
il a communiqué le nouveau numéro à
monsieur le chef de cabinet du préfet de
police à rien
né au prince qui est ce qu il a fait
signe au prince
pipi r tout de même ça t'a bien
simplifié la tâche à montfort al-bared
sans moi tu te serais fait penser ya
belle lurette azim tu t'énerves c'est un
groupe de tête fort tignes 252 millions
que tu caches ici dans nos colonnes du
mobilier national comme un paquet de
l'île année et 1 et qui me rendent fous
mais j'oublie le principal thème
principal la conscience professionnelle
quoi parfaitement ma conscience
professionnelle qui me torture nuitées
jour depuis tout ce temps je sais pas ce
qui montre bien que de t'arrêter
l'attention jules situe m'arrête moi je
parle tu parlerais tu m'as donné à toi
les passions d'une idole vous êtes
honnête appareils de vieux amis comme
vous attend ce soir comme ça non
on vous allez allez vous coucher demain
nous parlerons de tous âges au moment et
je suis sûr que nous nous entendrons
très bien c'est sabrina tu n as raison
ce champagne
nous avons été à la tête nous en parlons
vrai que ce qu'on fait pour le point
il fait le reste à sion à tout prix bon
ben c'est tout simple yakaar et étape
vous garez parfaitement food halal pour
avoir publié un article de nature à
troubler l'ordre public et l'ordre
public on ne doit pas transiger à cet
accord valorisant
allô monsieur située à fait injuste avec
lui nous lui devons pas tous aimait
beaucoup d'eau enfin c'est enfin je veux
dire un peu au début tout ce qu'il a
fait c'était pour nous qui était gentil
et il l'a fait sans se faire prendre
ceux qui étaient adroits et en plus il
s'est arrangé pour que nous puissions
faire semblant de ne rien savoir ce qui
est d'un ami dans leur gîte e mail
address la gentillesse l'amitié fans se
raye pas d'un go je sais qu'il aura
toujours les femmes pour lui parce que
monsieur étendons gelant peine on
connaît la dernière n'a il couche avec
gilberte arrivé c'était la meilleure
d'où le pauvre qu'est ce que tu dis
qu'il sera courte encore cédric albert
et la branche de gilberte en effet
depuis quand qui jadis avait rapport de
police sont formels les rapports de
police sur alter et je vais très mal et
la téléphonie là pour pour l'inviter
ce ne sont pas mes chéris les caucus a
toujours existé
c'est parce que la police est mal faite
à lécousse avec super u de france alors
il ne voit pas c'est une mante
religieuse imbécile at the block vivait
alors données montrent que notre ami le
mur
ça va nous dire ah non ça ne s'est pas
faite à madeleine le chat ça ne nous
regarde pas à pas je demande pardon
certain temps
et alors c'est avec super qu'il irait
claqué nous 252 millions en allant faire
la fête à paris ou ailleurs
peut-être même en lui offrant des bijoux
un super truc la paie de lait le nom de
152 millions lorsque dans sa non non je
ne supportais pas le jeu j'ai le prince
demande une arrestation demain matin
qu'il a fait arrêter albert difficile
pour le faut pour tout le peuple vous
pas arrêter pour cambriolage le propre
chef de cabinet du préfet de police
ça se fait pas à l'arrêter pour
cambriolage mais tu peut l'arrêter pour
complot tu vas arrêter albert pour ce
fameux complot il vient d'inventer ce
soir sans compter qu'un complot a l'air
toujours beaucoup plus vrai si la sat
est une autre personnalité de la police
et toi tu arrêtes albert pour complot et
tu découvre que c'est lui qui avait
bonne et les 252 millions pour financer
le mouvement
tu récupères le tout et tout le monde je
ne suis pas ce que dit un ennemi du
régime
un magistrat intègre refusent de
l'entendre on ne décollera pas j'ai eu
ce sera un prion adresse toi que j'ai
dit c'est le sondé poulaga à l'écart
[Applaudissements]
il
citoyenne notre élite traverse des
heures graves
cette année ça commence drôlement bien
en sept minutes ce sera elle
j'adresse à tous l appel solennel à ça
va pas ça fait deux fois sur l'année là
je te cherche donc tous ses amis ce ton
mais qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas pas et
ferais je trouve ça moi j'appelle à la
radio pour que je lirai aussitôt après
l'arrestation d'albert ou s'il albert et
vert et au bureau ou la veille ils
avaient un travail de finir son dernier
aval pour moi tout ne se doute de rien
c'est parfait citoyen
oui je crois qu'on est condamné à mort
albert m'ont même pas ce soir à la
prison à perpétuité
ça va être long la perpétuité à son art
peut-être un jour le projet d'accord
pour sa grâce pas tout de suite quand
même il faut qu'ils expliquent n'ont pas
tout de suite
j'adresse à tous un appel j'adresse à
tous un appel j'adresse à tous on
appelle là c'est ça qui verra bien si tu
réponds à cette satanée ça va pas du
tout il me faut absolument un adjectif à
cet endroit là dis moi comme détenus on
prévoit pour travailler dans le jardin
albert non mais tu ne penses pas un
prisonnier politique de masse qui voit
ses leur effet travaillé dur pour lui
apprendre
j'adresse ça tu vois ton les discours il
en a manqué il m'aurait trouvé ça en
moins de deux mais qu'est ce que tu veux
pas avoir de regrets normal aurait fini
par éclater 252,2 millions pour les
grilles surtout sur la conduite avec la
femme d'un des plus grands personnages
de l'état
ah oui à ce projet du nouveau un parent
inquiet se tromper il couche bien
avec la femme d'un cran personnage de
l'état mais c'est pas gildas privé
et tu ne lisez pas c'est ce que je fais
j'aime je te le dis c'est qui c'est un
grand personnage de l'état
on n'a pas su me le dire
je comprends suis tout ça est incroyable
c'est insensé
des inspecteurs a pu s'apercevoir un peu
plus tôt que c'était impensable et
impossible albert avec gilberte rivet ce
monde à moi tu saches le monde soit pour
l'anecdote d'abord il est célibataire
qui couche avec qui me plaît et ça ne
nous regarde pas seulement parce n'ont
pas cessé sa vie privée et la vie privée
c'est sacré qu'il est non je dois te
dire tout je n'ai pas fermé l'oeil de la
nuit
mais pourquoi elle a pensé de ce que tu
allais faire albert ton ami enfin
presque ton frère aussi je me suis mise
avoir de l'amitié pour lui que je
l'abats elle s'arrêtera bien aimé passer
il faut pas avoir peur des mots j'ai eu
ce que tu vas faire alger c'est une
femme abattue alors il faudrait savoir
ce que tu le sais que je veux c'est
qu'ils ne glissent pas comme le dernier
des derniers arrêtés albert
après tout ce qu'il a fait pour nous
après tout les risques qu'il a pris la
pluie surtout de 152 millions s'il peut
pas faire ça mais c'est à dire que vous
ne peut pas ne pas le faire j'en ai déjà
parlé aux français même si je vais mater
les premières heures et il lui a dit moi
on voit déjà que j'en ai dit comme chef
du contrôle
j'étais lambiel est accrue aussitôt un
faux complots a l'air beaucoup plus vrai
quand il à sa tête une autre
personnalité de la peur a reçu possible
du sein qui a réussi à ramener dans la
fin les 252 millions prix mais la
jeunesse et le suspense je le dis que de
ce côté là il n'est pas interdit de
penser que nous ayons des surprises que
les deux affaires étaient peut-être
liées
je fais des progrès et tout ça c'est
grâce à albert et que ce soit le dès
qu'il y en ait parlé le premier de ce
complot le prince n'aura pas été troublé
comme tu l'avais prévu navigator
raffinement de duplicité qui m'a
félicité pour ma perspicacité et pour
ton sens de l'amitié noah
justement c'est ce qui m'a épaté il m'a
dit je sais les sentiments d'amitié qui
vous liait à l'envié qu'il vous fait pas
retenu sur le chemin du bois suppose
écran c'est cornélien
tu as pris ça pour un compliment et
madame c'est un ton qui écornait moi
j'ai toujours pris racine
le pain se voulait qu'on le corps pas
tout de suite mais nous avons trouvé
mieux vous à faire ça en pleine séance
solennelle du parlement
quand le doyen pour annoncer l'ouverture
de la session frappe sur son bureau avec
son marteau d'ivoire c'est le signal
on se cherche on rit on embarque et on
récupère les 252 millions ce qui nous
sort une belle épine du pied
madeleine jeu j'attends pas relaté il ne
sait rien bien sûr mais il faut bien que
je le mette au courant pour cette
arrestation parce que tu vas arrêter
albert avec l'inde barlatier
mais tous les records de l'ignominie 122
ch région de mobiliser toutes les forces
de police du pays
en cachette du chef d'état major ne
fatigue pas rejeter coûts de
fonctionnement que tu prends soin eu la
responsabilité d'un acte et que tu
risques de temps va t'en qui attend et
n'oublient pas leur gaieté dans la tombe
et regarder qu'un c'est quand même mieux
racines
citoyen je ne peux pas laisser faire ça
je ne peux pas non plus renier albert ce
serait trahir tulle mon mari en fait
dramatique je ne les lis pas la tête au
fond du trou
à tout à l'heure car au c'est
traumatique
le voilà l'adjectif que je cherchais un
appel rama tic en sept minutes solennel
j'adresse à tous à l'ael traumatique au
au mieux en sept minutes dramatiques
j'adresse à tous un appel solennel c'est
ça qui est bien avec les objectifs
quand on a la chance d'en trouver deux
ils sont interchangeables bravo tu es
superbe mais que prépares tu l'as
indices pondre un oui non durant douze
ans plus tôt une à l'automne au p'tit
laius tue encore bien grand mot pour un
simple la us dramatique appel solennel
pour tout ce que vous savez j'ai jamais
lu le sens des nuances j'ai déjà eu du
mal à trouver ça pour toi le mandat du
cabardès de a écrites on l'a eu beau
proposer toujours te déranger notre pays
tient dans le matin papier je te le
fignoler pendant qu'il est habile à
écoute albert il faut que je t'avoue
tout ton idée le complot je n'ai utilisé
c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient laisser
empoisonner petit cachottier qu'est ce
que tu veux ce matin le prince m'a
encore convoqué porter pour les 252
millions alors moi d'être favorisé la
concentration
je lui ai parlé de ton complot je lui ai
dit que nous allons le démanteler
et à propos de ce complot n'existe pas
quenneville demain je prononcerai un
appel à la radio
et c'est cet appel que tu prépares voilà
vous avez tant de mal et ben oui il ya
20 minutes que je fais de suez et je
n'avance pas tu comment je voudrais dire
que le prince est toujours le bal
et que pour l'avenir ça va curieux qu'il
ait décidé de reprendre à son compte
cette histoire de complot non non ce
n'est pas une initiative de julia du
madeleine ladesou mettons nous dans la
sphère pour mieux la contrôler et si tu
mettais oui de chacun reste à son poste
et face à son goût un entretien très
bien les autorités suprêmes ont la
situation en main pour les autorités des
supprimes notre patrie bien l'aimer a
devant elle un avenir de paix de
concorde et de gloire
et tu as trouvé ça du projet de te
saoule de l'été sur de paix de concorde
et je termine film le prince alors tu me
prenais mon idée on n'a rien du fruit
hier je l'avais trouvée si mauvaise que
j'avais un peu honteux dollar provoque
lui avait bien à tort au dimanche je
veux mettre mes millions définitivement
à l'abri du célé les questions d'amour
propre et du voyage sûrs j'ai bien
l'intention de me faire oublier
je prends devant toi l'engagement
solennel de ne plus jamais cambriolé
même un tiroir caisse
la fin de carrière sera glorieuses et
paisible avait merci à mr jean
j'en haleine que cette vie là bas nous
étions en train de fignoler le discours
de jules quoi sais pas j'avais du mal à
deviner rituel tel joyau madeleine se
demande si le préfet d'urgence ont
toutes les deux on a dit qu on chante il
est imprudent de les laisser seuls tous
les deux ans d'absence madeleine ne
pourraient pas venir à berne oulala tout
ça est très embêtant il exagère le
prince a semé chevelure est toujours
faire avant la séance achevée de
m'habiller revoir mon discours pour voir
si tout va bien la crainte je l'enverrai
ton disent oh non j'aimerais mieux que
tu viens avec moi en pourquoi on ne l'a
pas demandé oui bon et culture que tu
n'as rien d'autre à faire ailleurs l'on
dit tout de suite que tu ne veux pas que
je reste seule avec ma à s'impatienter
bon alors j'y vais j'y vais aussi vite
qu chapelle et j'en reviens encore plus
vite a tout de suite à la dégustation
sur jules a tout découvert il ya
découvert que nous donnons c'est pas ça
du tout il fallait bien qu'elle ait lieu
un jour mais c'est toi qui l'a étonné
cette passion subite de l'honnêteté lit
où était passé tout des belles
déclarations sépare deux mois mais ce
cadeau d'autant plus que ces millions si
je vais les garder c'est pour toi c'est
pour nous
c'est moi qui l'ait mais juglar et or
est impossible pour qu'il ne se laisse
pas arrêter je vais lui dire que je
pense que le faux complots en dissimule
un vrai il se méfiera pourquoi toutes
ces cachotteries à la madeleine chéri
cash à ce complot dont tu as parlé au
prince était un faux complot mais il y
en a un autre un vrai celui-là que dis
tu laboures jouer les innocents qui est
parfaitement au courant je le sais c'est
le trop malade pour l'ignorer samassa
mars
maintenant il faut le prévenir du piège
du parlement qu'ils n'assistent surtout
pas à la séance à ne me dis pas que tu
ne connais pas leurs achats à fleurs à
la minute m
celle où tout se déclenchera pendant la
séance du parlement
quand le doyen frappe ce son bureau avec
son marteau d'ivoire c'est le signal ne
me dis pas que tu ne savais pas à qui
l'on doit le recevoir
je te laisse mes méfie-toi attention à
ce que tu dis oui
bonjour c'est le chef de cabinet
monsieur le préfet m'avait convoqué il
n'est pas là à mon bonheur c'est le chef
de cabinet j'ai une question à vous
poser mon commandant que savez vous du
complot le complot c'est la question de
la plus vicieuse cour supérieure qui se
pose est un policier si je réponds quel
complot il va penser que je suis
incapable de n'être pas au courant
bien au contraire que je joue les
incapables et que par conséquent où j'en
suis et il faut répondre vite mon
silence n'a que trop duré eh bien
monsieur le préfet il ne se passe pas de
soucis chez veille dessus quoi
travailler dans qu'il existe depuis le
premier jour et pourquoi nous n'avons
rien dit parce que parce que je ne
voulais pas inquiété mais supérieure
avec une affaire que nous serions de
chypre aigles qu'elle n'a aucune chance
d'aboutir et qui pendant ce temps après
des membres sur cette table de ne faut
rien exagérer la preuve c'est qu'elle
est tout de même arrivé jusqu'à nos
oreilles
et qu'avez vous décidé d'y mettre fin 2
on avait dans son chef sans chef
son chef au complot à trois chiens je
dirais même qu'il n'existe que slash des
victimes f1 ton art en chef sans gêne
son chef dans les plus brefs délais
bravo encore faut-il que je sache ou qui
sait le chef
mais qui peut bien être ce chef et vous
êtes au courant de leurs achats et de la
minute m au-dessus maintien du signal à
la séance du parlement
quand le doyen frappe son bureau avec
son marteau robert c'est tout simple à
la minute m
nous on se précipite sur lui et on
embarque lui qui est bien le chef
parbleu bien sûr le chef
bon eh bien monsieur le chef de cabinet
gianni mettre le dispositif en place à
partir de 7 minutes tout le monde est
suspect au revoir monsieur fhf
ce grand plan chéri ce complot que tu
croyais que je te cacher dont je te jure
je ne savais rien bah relatifs est au
courant par la petite couronne
mais c'est un fouet mais pourquoi
n'avait-il rien dit je n'en ai pas la
moindre idée
il n'ya fait l'explication il en est
complice peut-être même en est-il le
chef à berre il faut arrêter par la
quille ça résoudrait tous et pour la
sécurité future des millions de sarah
une précaution supplémentaire s'opérer
ça on arrête par led font l'art est tout
de suite pas du tout on va le faire
arrêter à la séance du parlement à la
minute même le doyen frappe ce son
bureau avec son marteau
il se méfiera de rien il coiffe minutes
on va arrêter quelqu'un et c'est lui
qu'on arrête à l'effet de surprise sera
total des dépôts crime sa part la tiéfo
quatrième canon l'a rendu fou mais
répartie et dans sa chambre jur mois a
continué à dix mois de travail mais qui
est mon mari
c'est vrai nom tant que moine à vienne
je perds un peu la tête avec tout ce que
voulait la france que je calme seule
inquiétude il voulait savoir si j'étais
sûr d'être en coupe d afrique et de
barbarie nazie
oui tu m'as mais oui tout est sûre de
barratier et bien sûr pouvoir barratier
et d'être au courant du complot non si
il ya peut-être un second complot un
vrai celui-là qui se dissimuleraient
derrière le fond est ce lui même se
méfier de barlatier
pour me donner leur fait peur c'est moi
écoute moi bien la personne qui a le
plus d'intérêt à être dans un complot
mais tu n'es pas c'est évidemment celle
qui prendra ta place si le complot
triomphe est celui mineurs alors moi à
ta place je ne prendrai pas de risques
j'arrêterai par la romieu
encore plus vrai faut que tu arrêtes
quelques jamais pensé oui j'avais pensé
mais là c'est vrai il y avait pensé
actuellement la mairie à 10 h le taux
n'avait rien dit il reste sans doute
oublié je fais jamais oublier l'univers
éthiques
et bien voilà je me dis je je je me
demande et je cherchais une femme ne
cherche plus tu vas arrêter par lettre à
toi aussi pourquoi moi aussi mais parce
que je suis sûr que non c'est ce que me
disait malgré les grands esprits se
rencontrent mais enfin pourquoi par
métier pourquoi pas par la team et après
tout pourquoi pas dans la drôme
l'ardèche et savoir évidemment pas
relaté au courant du complot ça change
tout mais le prime ce qui me demandent
si je réponds de lui tout seul est très
embêtant tu ne devrait pas recevoir
malatier timati treicheville pour qui tu
me feras on fait attention au gym
c'est la tension fait attention jules je
fais attention tu arrêter comme ça y est
j'ai mis en place un dispositif plus
grosses urgences immédiates toutes les
groupes sont consignées toutes les
phases de ruck doublé coup les effectifs
des postes haut de gamme x 4 et changer
toutes les 2 heures toutes les avenues
sont surveillés 12 brigades spéciales
sont prêtes à intervenir au moindre
signal ou palais comme l'assemblée ne
peut pas nous échapper pas avant l'idéal
ce serait que notre massis de la séance
du parlement grec
ah bon et pourquoi dans parce que là
j'ai une idée qui va sûrement vous
épater si nous avions la chose qui soit
là où on précise le doyen frappe son
bureau avec son marteau d'ivoire pour
annoncer solennellement que la session
est ouverte
ce serait la minute m qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous avez trouvé ça tout seul
est ce que steve en général certaines
bas à genève est la personne jusqu'à la
mine de l'arrestation le nom du chef de
complot je me précipite sur lui mais ça
ne me suivent
il en est celui qui joue à fond c'est un
peu clément aveuglément aveuglément même
si c'était vous et ce même si c'était
moi mais vous êtes fous rires je
plaisante de ce pavé bien sûr reconnaît
pas cette plaisanterie au pardon pas du
tout excuser moi renoncer parce qu'on
fait du contexte je parle à tout le
monde est et sebastian et albert avait
raison oh la la
attention au jules attention attention
[Musique]
personne ne sera donc jusqu'au dernier
moment que ces nantais l'audience lundi
olala c'est le moment d'être prudent
mais celle du complot c'est monsieur
landré total a vu quand le troyen
frappera sur son bureau avec son marteau
d'ivoire c'est le signal c'est sur lui
qu'il faudra vous choquer sur l'entier
oui et si ça peut vous donner du coeur à
l'ouvragé
sachez que vous arrêté en même temps le
cambrioleur des 252 millions parce que
des coques l'irlande il se dit je vais
me l'a dit lui-même lunel oui c'est
bizarre ça tu vas voir ta à l'assemblée
tu dois encore ajuster tombe encore dont
il sait qu'il n'est jamais droite
renchérit fabien comme tout tout tout
tout nous allons embarquer l'envié ça va
être sanglant
bravo puisque c'est ce que vous avez
décidé
il ne vous reste plus qu'à être
optimiste j'espère pour vous que tout se
passera bien que voulez-vous dire ou
penser que ça peut se passer entre nous
et je poste national l'envié fort très
fort très fort
favre a réussi à monter son complot sans
que personne ou presque ne se doute de
rien c'est fort très fort très fort
il ya tension il connaît tous les
rouages de la police ont toutes nos
faiblesses
tous souhaitent avoir des hommes à lui à
chaque poste que les complices
il est fort très fort très fort et il a
beaucoup d'argent
252 millions qu'il a donnée pardon si la
volée pour financer la révolution et que
la révolution l'emportent ce n'est plus
un vol
ça devient un emprunt patriotique qui
n'aura aucune peine à rembourser
surtout qu'il aura la planche à billets
natif tenant en cash soit lui qui vous
ai dit qu'il avait volé les 252 millions
c'est bizarre quand même
oui en effet c'est bizarre ce qui est
bizarre aussi c'est que ça lui qui m'a
parlé le premier du complot non en fait
on ne s'est pas fait chez lui à faire
incompris landier sait très bien qu'il
ne peut pas faire triompher son complot
tout seul il a besoin d'un second il
vous a fait des offres à boire mais
c'est évident c'est entre les belles
mais c'est vrai après tout il a
peut-être fait des offres mais j'y pense
moi aussi quand il m'a avoué c'était lui
le cambrioleur quelque 152 millions à
moi aussi il a peut-être fait qui
s'offrent à vous pourquoi pas moi enfin
pourquoi pas lui il était bien mal tombé
avec nous sommes le jaune de te voir un
enfant dont on ne voit personne n'en
doute dans l'allier justin a plus que
quelques secondes pour ajuster ton grand
cortège érigé et si sa salle par de
préfète et du complot il a eu très peur
tout à l'heure quand j'avais dit que je
la retraite c'est un avis il faut
absolument que nous allons dire on lui
rappelle une île avec des offres
j'ai l'envié
j'en suis je ne m'attarde ont j'en suis
vous en êtes
oui il y avait un moment de la vie autre
conscience de son choix sans hésiter à
la formidable ce catch sont froides
cette faculté de dissimulation vous êtes
un vrai chef vous savez ce sale goût de
préfet a tout organisé pour vous faire
arrêter le signal s'est fait quand il
doit y être absent durant avec son
marteau
c'est vrai vous saviez vous c'est vous
qui me l'avait dit il fallait vous soyez
sûr de votre affaire pour m'en parler
comme ça en toute confiance une
confiance bien placé c'est par la biais
qui vous le dit
nous allons mettre ensemble à ce régime
de corruption tous les quatre seront
châtiés ne prennent pas le premier vous
avez volé près toutes les forces de
police occupe le parlement mais c'est
moi qui les commandent et je suis avec
vous révolution valtra c'est ça ça n'est
pas très clair mais ce qui est clair et
même lumineux c'est que c'est le moment
de prendre mes millions et le filet
avais je suis pour ma part je me suis tu
en es ne me dis pas que tu ne veut pas
de moi je sais plus bien sûr je sais
tout ce [ __ ] de barleté a tout
arrangé pour parité ce matin en pleine
séance du parlement et le doyen train de
se son bureau avec son marteau
formidable tu es formidable et elle a
formidablement organisées dont complot
mais je suis avec toi et nous allons
coffret se fragmente pas relaté au
moment où j attende allemagne
parachevait mariga les révolutions aka
monsieur l'ensci s'enfuir à sa merci
révolution c'est ça quand je peux alors
je vais vous confier une mission de la
plus grande importance
vous allez préparer la voiture qui doit
donner s'il le faut l'assaut au palais
prenez la plus rapide de nos voitures
chicago fait me faire le plein prévoyez
deux jerricanes de réserve et tenait là
prête à foncer devant la porte de
service
jb cheikh attendait par l'ati rassemblés
au parlement toutes les chances de
police at il pensé aux agents de la
circulation très propre chef
je veux qu'ils en soient aussi aller à
la préfecture de police est donné à tous
les agents l'ordre de rejoindre
immédiatement le parlement j'y mets
chefs et les matins chef mais mort à
toutes les patrouilles de motards qui
rentrent immédiatement bien chef même
ordre pour les gardes frontières ggf et
revient du chef chef l'évolution
voilà on va maintenant
je suis de n'avoir pas douter de moi mon
amour je serai les chevilles de la
révolution plus en france la révolution
c'est la jeunesse la révolution c'est
l'intelligence la révolution c'est
l'amour je savais tout et tu sais tout
depuis le début la liberté et guident
nos pas et la victoire nous ouvre la
barre s'est passé à cet âge est très
mince aspirateur james au rang de héros
que pour cent entre les couronnes et
cette course cette bouche qui la
première a crié mort au tyran tu peux y
aller albert les femmes sont avec toi ça
a tout à leur chéri sur la plus haute
marche de l'escalier de la gloire d'un
duo - révolution
[Applaudissements]
alors là ça fait sens
deux cents ce sont des pièces en pièces
bon alors qu'est ce qui a pu se payer un
seul policier qui n'aboie pas parlement
hoarau pour y aller la voiture est qu'à
la place dans l'escalier thierry
attendait quand je peux donner bonne et
ses deux valises et descendez jusqu'à la
voiture c'est elle qui vont descendre ou
sans lui ce sont les dossiers de la
conspiration
tenez en lieu sûr je veux rejoindre un
instant gâcher les sorties un temps à
les y pousse or le temps presse vote en
france et puis ça s'entassent à
s'entassent fayel ronan était acquis
le prince jean oui bon vieux le coup
d'état réussi au signal aux coups de
marteau je vois par là qui suivit de ses
hommes se lever et se précipiter sur moi
alors mon dieu je ne cite pas je fonce
sur le fauteuil du prince au dernier
moment je pète et toulouse homme se
précipite sur le prince et l'embarquent
à la sec secret pour ceux qui agissent
au nom de la révolution je vous arrête
foot ou les deux qu'est ce qui vous pend
il nous a trahis pas du tout celui
comment ce matin j'ai dit vous même
tendu un piège lui est tombé dessus du
complot
sans triomphe partout on arrêtait le
prince on arrêtait rizet on arrêtait sa
famille a été la moitié des députés
c'était obligé avec tous ces policiers
autour chacun voulait embarquer tient au
milieu de la mêlée
je saute sur le plus rock et royal et je
cuisine landier mais quelques dpp encore
bonnie bp se joignent à moi depuis
qu'est ce qui les sauve les députés
c'est formidable ça sur ta légitimité
blévin ici et en font d'autant tous
ensemble qui vit mme losier c'est pour
l'histoire
huit longueurs avoue surtout janvier ont
tout bloqué
au fond c'est bien pour ça que j'ai en
tête un complot mais c'est d'un photo il
est en plus à d'autres sommes au courant
depuis le premier jour figurez-vous mais
pas du tout à tuer mais je n'ai pas de
ce pouvoir
on va nous faire ça padoan baisse est
impossible de connaître le garder mais
maintenant c'est trop tard elle pouvons
plus aller rechercher la solution
viendrait plus longtemps une fois je ne
vous ai rien demandé moi je te prendre
plusieurs pouvoirs que prétend vous
apporter je serai le parti ne veut rien
devoir à ce pour écouler les comment
allez vous taire tous les deux c'est à
cause de fautes et qu'il refuse des
landiers je ne pouvais pas nier que vous
avez été l'inspirateur il stratège de
notre coopération
celui à qui notre cause doit d'avoir
triomphé pas du tout jeune et je n'ai
absolument pas et avec ça vous lirez
encore regarder tout ce que j'espère
c'est la photo de notre chef nous nous
avons décidé de ne cesser le combat qu
après la victoire nous avons prêté
serment devant son nez fiché deux fois
que je peux plus lire ses clients qu'est
ce que c'est que ce million si ce n'est
pas le trésor de la conspiration
l'agent de la liberté destiné à financer
le mouvement est jamais caché chez moi
ça c'est une preuve de confiance
l'équation est si ce n'est pas l'argent
de la liberté alors c'est de l'argent
volé dans ces conditions on est obligé
de ton barque et messieurs si la patrie
a besoin de moi
leur annonçait smic touax est plus vieux
os
c'est que ce sont valables karim j'ai eu
un taux discount claude et court 10
coups mais mon discours mais je suis
comme je l'étais je n'ai pas écrit pour
ça c'est bien que ça va pour toutes les
occasions
c'est fait exprès allez je suis citoyen
citoyens notre pays traverse des heures
graves
en ces circonstances dramatiques
j'adresse à tous un appel solennel que
chacun à son poste fasse son devoir
les autorités suprêmes ont la situation
en main notre patrie bienvenue mais a
devant elle un avenir de paix et de
concorde et de coin vivent dans dit
langer
oh
il
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous et de raymond castans
la mise en scène et de jacques charon
les décors sont andré levasseur
et les costumes de donald cardwell
avec andré fauté
jacques c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
bibi
henri dix ans
et marthe mercadier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]